This is Jocko podcast number one 40 with Echo Charles and me,
Jocko Willink.
Good Evening Echo.
Good evening.
If you can keep your head when all about you are losing theirs and blaming it on
you.
If you can trust yourself when all men doubt you but make allowance for their
doubting too.
If you can wait and not be tired by waiting or being lied about,
don't deal in lies or being hated.
Don't give way to hating and yet don't look too good nor talk too wise
if you can dream and not make dreams your master.
If you can think and not make thoughts your aim.
Yeah.
If you can meet triumph and disaster and treat those two imposters just the
same.
If you can bear to hear the truth,
you've spoken twisted by Knaves to make a trap for fools or watch the things you
gave your life to broken
and stoop and build them up with worn out tools.
If you can make one heap of all your winnings and risk it on one turn of pitch
and toss and lose and start again at your beginnings and never breathe a word
about your loss.
If you can force your heart and nerve and sinew to serve your turn long after
they are gone.
And so hold on when there is nothing in you except the will which says to them,
hold on.
If you can talk with crowds and keep your virtue or walk with kings nor lose the
common touch.
If neither foes nor loving friends can hurt you if all men count with you.
But none too much.
Okay.
If you can fill the unforgiving minute with 60 seconds worth of distance run,
yours is the earth and everything that's in it and which is more,
you'll be a man.
My son.
Yeah,
and
that of course is the classic poem,
which is called if it's by Rudyard Kipling and of course we have covered some of
his less,
I guess famous has less famous poems on this podcast.
We covered infantry columns,
which a lot of people don't know the name,
infantry columns,
but that's the,
the the poem that talks about boots,
boots,
moving up and down.
Yeah,
that one we read the young British soldier,
which is about Afghanistan.
We wrote,
we read a bit of Tommy and of course Kipling was an incredible writer and he
talked a lot about war,
talked a lot about being a man and his own son.
His one son,
John,
was killed in world war one at the battle of Loos and
these are great poems and I recently read a poem called a mental cases by
Wilfred Owen.
And when we got done with that podcast,
I actually said,
I should have read it again.
Then I did and I said,
hey,
go back to the beginning and listened to it again,
but I should have actually picked it apart a little bit because it's kind of
like what I said about Shakespeare when we did Henry the fifth and I said,
you can't get frustrated with Shakespeare.
You can't think that you're just going to read Shakespeare and just get it.
It just doesn't,
it doesn't work that way.
There's more to it than that.
There's more depth there.
There's words you might not know.
There's references that might not be obvious.
There's,
it's,
it's the same thing when you look at poems like this,
there's more to them than you can get with just like reading it,
right.
There's,
there's layers lose what we're talking about.
So the,
the poem that I just read,
if is,
like I said,
it's a classic,
it's read often it should be red.
But there's,
and best part of the reason why I didn't cover it for a long time cause I kind
of thought everyone just knew it.
Not everyone ral yeah,
everyone knows that.
Everyone knows that poem.
Everyone's read that poem.
But it's actually not true.
And talk to a lot of people.
And I tell,
yeah,
it's like leaf and they say,
Oh what's that?
So in order to sort of solve that problem we covered on the podcast and now
people will hear this poem and learn from it.
And I want to spend a little bit of time breaking it down cause there's all
kinds of important lessons in it that are really solid,
really solid guidance.
And then when we understand it,
then I'll go back and read it again.
The way it's supposed to hit you when you know what's going on.
So breaking it down a little bit.
There's an end,
there's themes in this that we've heard I've talked about,
and they're just consistent through time.
So here it starts off.
If you can keep your head when all about you are losing theirs and blaming it on
you,
there's this one's pretty self explanatory.
Keep your head,
don't lose your temper,
stifle your emotions as I want.
Sat on his podcast and it's saying,
especially when everyone else around you is not only losing their temper,
but on top of that,
they're blaming you.
Hmm.
This is a little bit of ownership here.
This is a little bit of extreme ownership and I've talked about that.
When someone blames you for something,
you know what you do,
what you say.
Yeah,
you're right.
It is my fault.
This is what I'm going to do to fix it.
You pathetic.
You don't say that part.
You keep that to yourself.
When,
when there's a problem and people I blame you,
don't under you own it,
own it.
And don't lose your temper.
Stifle your motions.
Next line,
if you can trust yourself when all men doubt you,
but make allowance for their doubting too.
There's a little dichotomy here,
right?
So you gotta be confident,
of course,
right?
Trust yourself.
That's what it means to believe in yourself.
Even when other people are doubting you.
You got to trust that you're doing the right thing.
You've got to trust that you're capable.
You got to trust that you can make this happen.
That's what it means to trust yourself when all men value.
But there's a dichotomy here and this is so important cause that,
cause what?
That means,
what that one line alone could lead to is a,
Hey,
I'm just gonna be overconfident,
right?
I'm confident.
Hey,
I'm right.
Everyone else is wrong.
You don't get it.
That's not what's being said here.
Cause there's a,
but that's the dichotomy part.
The,
but is a dichotomy partner because while you got to believe in yourself,
yes,
and at the same time you also have to make allowance for their doubts.
That means you have to understand that you might have some issues,
you might not be perfect,
you might be wrong.
You might not be as smart or as talented or as squared away as you think you
are.
And your idea that you came up with might not be the best one.
So yes,
you've got to have confidence.
Even when people are down and you booked,
you kind of remember that they could be down in you for a good reason.
You could be wrong.
You should always have that in the back of your head.
That's the dichotomy.
Humble,
confident,
but humble.
That's what we're talking about.
Next line,
if you can wait and not be tired by waiting
patients,
it's about patients.
I think I've told this,
if I told the story about being on a ship and waiting for Chow,
not that I can remember.
Okay.
So I was on my first deployment as a seal on a ship in the navy were overseas
where we're spending a lot of time at sea and to eat food,
which was,
I'm not going to say it was scarce,
but they feed you three times a day and,
and all that type of ship.
I was on an amphibious ship.
There's uh,
several hundred marines on board.
Obviously there's the sailors that run the ship,
their seals.
We're,
you know,
an 18 man seal platoon on there,
but everyone's gotta be fed.
What does child time and so everyone would go line up for chow.
You get in line in the line would be long and depending on how hungry you are,
maybe you want to get up there a little early anyways to make a long story short
so we get in line and whatever,
whatever reason they got this rule that you're not allowed to lean on the
bulkhead.
The bulkhead is in a plane.
I do,
you know,
playing,
what is it?
That front part,
yeah,
that's a fun on,
it's a wall basically on a ship or an aircraft.
It's a wall to bulkhead.
So for whatever reason in the navy is standing in the chow line,
you're not supposed to lean on the bulkhead.
So imagine this,
you're going to be standing there for your standing three inches from a wall,
but you're not supposed to lean on it.
Yeah.
Now this isn't a three minute stand.
This is half an hour.
This is 40 minutes waiting for the chow to open up and then serve everybody.
And I remember I learned something about patients because then you get these
guys that
you know the people that they have a little bit of authority and they're going
to use it and if given the opportunity they will abuse it,
they're going to take it to the next level.
So there'd be some guys,
not all of them.
I was always my goal to make friends with anybody that had anything to do with
feeding us on a ship.
I wanted to be there bro.
Because then you get in a couple of extra chicken nuggets,
you know,
so you get an extra scoop full of Ravioli,
which is,
which is important,
important,
big time.
Especially when you're trying to pack on the mass.
Right.
So I tried to be friends with all those people,
but some of those guys,
they didn't care about friends.
Right.
They had that authority.
And one,
there's one guy,
I remember he had the authority,
it was,
he was in charge of making sure that line was,
you know,
maintained discipline in the line.
That was his deal.
He has a badge of some kind.
I want to say he was a master at arms,
which is a,
uh,
a job in the navy.
I think he,
this guy was actually a master at arms [inaudible] we had some kind of badge.
Right?
So that takes that authority attitude up.
One maybe two notches.
He's coming at you.
So,
so I'm standing in line one day and I'm leaning on the bulkhead.
Am I being a little bit lazy?
Sure.
Um,
I'm telling you,
it's a long deployment,
right?
I've laid it on the bolt kit.
He comes over.
Hey,
no leaning on the bulkhead.
Hmm.
You know what I did?
What?
Got Off the bulkhead?
I just stood up straight,
didn't get mad,
didn't get angry.
He's doing his job.
Not supposed to leave on the bulkhead.
Just normal face.
Was I a broken man?
Once I broken Matt did my,
did my will break.
I don't think so.
What I did was I accepted.
I was able to wait and not be tired by waiting.
So be patient.
This,
this,
the moral of that line will technically you weren't able to eat without getting
tired cause he leaned on the bulkhead.
Right?
You got corrected,
corrected and then I got an tired.
All right.
Next line or being lied about.
Don't deal in lies.
People are going to lie about you.
Tell the truth.
Tell the truth about what's going on.
Getting caught in the web of lies.
Not Fun.
No,
not fun.
Then you see,
she had happened with people.
I'm trying to think.
Do you remember when you're a little kid and you'd think you'd get away with
some little web of lies?
Oh yeah.
Like or you see your kids do it.
Yeah.
They just tell a little lie about something and the web encapsulates him.
But adults do that too.
You know?
Let me see that happen.
You see that happen with uh,
in politics?
Yeah.
You know,
I never did this.
You know what I mean?
And then they have video,
they have audio,
and it's just if that person would have said,
hey,
this is what I did,
this is what I did.
I'm sorry.
It's a bad mistake.
I,
I throw myself to the judgment of the people.
Right.
Okay,
fair enough.
Yeah.
But instead they make up some lie about,
I'm trying to remember,
I mean,
I've never seen that woman before in my life.
Oh really?
We have a video of you apparently quite acquainted with as a woman or whatever.
So yeah,
don't get into the web of lies.
It is not going to help you next line or being hated.
Don't give way to hating.
Now what's interesting about this is we actually have a name for these people
now.
Right?
Haters.
Right.
That's a new word.
I don't think there was such a thing as haters when I was a kid.
There was no such thing as haters.
Yeah.
Was someone that didn't like you,
you wouldn't say that's person's a hater.
Yeah.
No,
it wasn't a thing.
Well,
there's the added,
like sprinkled in element.
When you say hate hater haters,
typically it's like someone that hates everybody.
Know someone who hates everything.
No.
It's when there's an element of jealousy in there.
That's what,
that's what a hater.
Okay.
So I actually nailed this then.
I actually,
so as I was thinking about this,
that's kind of what I thought.
Some people aren't gonna like you for whatever reason,
but oftentimes the reason isn't you.
It's actually them.
Yeah.
That's,
it hits them.
It's there.
They hate your success.
They hate your happiness.
They hate their day,
hate the fact that you've got whatever it is that they want.
Right.
That's jealousy.
So yeah,
some people are going to get,
you know,
if they're going to be haters.
Yeah.
And so the recommendation here is don't,
don't,
don't give it back to him.
Yeah.
Okay.
There's a,
you ever heard that the opposite of love isn't hate.
The opposite of love is indifference.
Yeah.
So the opposite of hate,
it's indifference to,
right.
Yeah.
Whatever.
That's sort of my recommended recommended course of action.
Someone that hates the fact that you're winning.
I kind of feel sorry for him.
Right.
But yeah,
everyone kind of in the past that I guess,
yeah,
if you get by the emotional part when someone's hating on you,
um,
yeah,
you do kind of fee.
I mean you can,
depends on who you are I guess.
But you can kind of feel sorry for him cause it's like,
it's kind of a lonely,
like actually I think,
I think when I say I feel sorry for him,
I think that's almost like a little bit of a,
that's a little bit of ego of mine to have like a little dig.
Like,
like I feel sorry for that defense mechanism of my own.
I think,
you know what I mean?
It's kind of a,
it's kind of a back,
it's a backhanded insult.
You don't,
Oh,
oh,
you know,
Echo said this about you.
You know,
I actually feel sorry for him.
It's almost like that guy is so low.
So there's,
I think there's a little bit of ego there,
but from the airport when I say something like that,
so that's why I think in differences might maybe the better step.
Like,
Hey,
whatever,
man,
hey,
some people are going to like me,
some people on this,
I'm good with it.
Or bring it on over here.
Work to do.
There's a culture of embracing that to,
you know,
help people be like,
hey,
if you're,
if you don't have haters,
you're doing something wrong,
or something like that.
Like don't say that kind of stuff
to me.
You know how you talk about how someone says,
Hey,
that's just the way I am.
That's my personality.
To me,
that is brushing up against it.
Right?
Some people,
groups,
when people gonna hate me,
that's the way it is.
It's like,
no,
actually,
yeah.
Let's think about at least let's account for it a little bit.
Let's,
let's figure out maybe why.
Yeah,
yeah.
Actually sometimes,
I mean,
this is kind of a smaller deal than even warrants me talking about it,
but something tells me you're going to do it anyway anyway.
I mean,
in the spirit of trying to understand the nature of haters,
and we're actually talking on a podcast right now about the nature of haters.
Well,
some would say,
hey,
if you don't have haters,
you're doing something wrong.
Meaning you're not doing something big enough for the jealous people in the
world to be jealous.
This is a whole,
this is a whole area that we just don't want it.
Right.
I mean seriously.
This is like,
it's true.
This is like the area that we're just not that,
that's why I think that's what's good.
What the statement here.
Don't being hated.
Don't give way to hating.
Move on.
Let's not worry about it.
Yeah.
And next line,
cause that's analyze it
all right next and yet don't look too good nor talk too wise.
Don't look too good nor talk too wise.
So this is,
this is important because this is a little bit of a dichotomy too of hey,
don't give way to hating,
don't deal in lies,
but at the same time saying don't look too good or talk too.
Why?
So
you gotta keep it real basically.
And you don't want to be a know it all.
You don't want to talk down to people.
You don't want to be the,
the,
the person that comes across like,
oh,
I would,
um,
virtuous,
I'm more virtuous than you.
That's what that line is,
right.
Don't try and look too good.
Like,
you would never do anything wrong.
It's like,
oh,
that guy got in trouble.
That guy got caught in a web of lies instead of,
you know,
jump.
It's like,
okay,
you know what?
He made a mistake.
Hope.
Good luck to him.
I hope he can figure it out.
It'll be,
finds the right path out of his situation instead of talking like,
Oh,
I'm,
I,
that would never happen to me because I am virtuous.
Yeah.
Or talk too wise,
which is,
you know,
I know everything,
right?
Yeah.
I think that's,
yeah.
People that are trying to come across,
you know what?
Remember when we were on with Captain Charlie Plumb and Jim Kunkel and they were
trying to drag me into the being like them.
They're,
you know,
they're like,
hey,
you know what?
We're warrior warriors like you,
Jocko.
And I was like,
no,
guys don't know.
You guys are totally like,
not just,
not just like more heroic than me,
but on top of that better people.
Like I'm like a rat running around compared to those guys and,
and so,
yeah,
I'm not ever trying to be,
you know,
a guy that's saying,
oh yeah,
well I'm,
I'm,
I'm virtuous in year,
not,
no.
Hey Man,
we're all struggling.
Yeah.
Could this mean to,
you know,
it don't look too good nor to Wa like,
um,
you know how,
okay,
this is the concept where you don't want people make speeches or they'll sit,
they'll have some sales pitch or something and they'll want every word to be
perfect.
But then when a,
when a sales pitch is like super perfect,
it doesn't connect as well as if it's just a person talking normal to you.
You know what I'm saying?
And all this,
uh,
just that idea,
you know,
like,
so if someone's focusing so hard and being like perfect in every way and like
knowing every single possible thing and just not showing any flaws,
like focusing on it,
maybe that's a mistake because they kind of created a disconnect.
I actually,
I don't think that's what this is talking about,
but I think it is correct.
So I'm going to give you an example from my perspective.
One of the reasons that podcasts right now do really well is because they're
normal people talking like normal people.
And I think that if,
if pot,
and there are podcasts out there that are way polished and everything,
and I don't like to listen to those podcasts that are all polished,
right.
I don't,
there's very few actually,
I can't think of any,
any of the podcasts that I actually like our,
the,
our polished to that nth degree.
Right.
Cause that's when you're talking about,
you know,
a highly produced with the background music and the,
all that stuff,
like those podcasts,
I don't,
I don't like those as much.
Yeah.
I like those.
But,
and even when you talk about the produced pocket,
like hardcore history,
he's still talking.
He know he's,
I mean obviously Joe Rogan,
obviously Tim Ferris,
even martyrmade,
right.
Martyrmade he's,
he's,
he's talking,
right.
He's not just making things happen.
So
I think there's something to that.
There's something to the fact that we're not talking about doing everything
perfect.
For sure.
Yeah,
for sure.
Yeah.
Agree.
I think if if this podcast,
well this podcast would be sound like,
it'd be like welcome to welcome to the Jocko podcast.
This is episode 140 we're here to talk to you today about,
or Richard Kipling.
He was born in pop by and just one of those who wants to listen to that.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
If it sounds like,
well,
cause,
because I think anyway,
and it has a lot to do with like what you're used to,
you know,
where like if you're used to like a polished presentation and then all of a
sudden it's not polished,
it's like,
oh,
he kind of fumbled through that.
Well,
there's a difference between not polished and I've also heard podcasts that are
not prepared or not professional.
Right.
That's another,
the other end of spectrum.
And you can,
there's a dichotomy because you can go too far.
Sometimes I think people just,
they think,
well Joe Rogan,
he just presses record and talks.
Yeah.
And they think that that's just what that is.
Oh,
I can do that.
I'll just press record and I'll talk with this other guy.
And then you,
then you listen to them and you think there's a reason why Joe Rogan is so
popular?
Yes sir.
The reason that Joe Rogan so popular is because even when he's just conversing,
he's got a skillset that he was probably born with and then he honed it as a
comedian and then he honed it as an actor.
Then he owned it as a,
as an announcer for the UFC.
And then he started this podcast and so he was already good at it.
And then he's done 1500 pound casts that are two,
three and four hours long.
So guess what?
You get good at figuring out.
You listened to yourself and go,
oh,
that didn't sound good.
And so,
so there's a big difference.
Yes,
there's podcasts that people just think they're going to hit record and just
talk and then it's going to be super cool dichotomy,
not cool.
It's hard to listen to.
Some of those are hard to listen to.
Got To gut through them.
So check.
All right,
next line.
If you can dream and not make dreams your master,
that one's
pretty pretty.
That's a pretty awesome line,
right?
That's a pretty awesome line.
And there's,
it's a dichotomy.
Yes.
Dream,
but don't make them your master.
Don't make dreams your living reality,
right?
Live in reality,
not in the world to dreams.
If your dreams are your master,
what are you actually doing?
Daydreaming,
daydream,
and all day you gotta make something happen.
That's what's got to go down next.
Very similar if you can think and not make thoughts,
your aim.
So yes,
of course thing.
Okay?
But don't make your goal to sit around and think,
and I think in my mind when I hear this and maybe I'm my own personal biases
coming into it,
this seems like a little shot at philosophers and academics,
right?
That sit around all day and what they're doing is they're thinking that's what
they do.
A little shot at those
cause don't make thoughts your aim.
You want to actually go and do things.
You want to make things happen.
You want to live.
Hmm.
There's a difference there.
Yeah.
And that's actually,
that's like a cause you know how like I feel like you're kind of the example of
that.
Like when I start saying eat,
whether it be on this thing or,
or even in real life where I'll start explaining something cause I'll be super
interested in like how this thing works and hey,
did you see what happened?
Explain it.
And then your attitude is always been like,
yeah,
okay.
Like,
okay,
give me an example.
Who um,
what do you mean by real life?
The outside of recording all like analyze.
Like if someone's,
like if I were to talk about haters,
like I could analyze that.
Like it's a separate podcast,
Charles podcasts of like,
you know what people have dynamics of haters to episode one.
How people might be a whole series bro maybe.
But you'll be like,
all right,
you know,
okay,
we understand is you,
you do it for more like,
hey,
we're going to understand so we can take action or you know,
whatever.
I'll,
I'll just explain the understanding because it's fun to explain the
understanding and see what I'm saying.
I'm looking for application of that knowledge to usually leadership situations.
Yes.
Yes,
exactly.
Right.
And then you'll,
it seems like,
like you'll dig into like understanding it like as deep as you have to take
action and that's it.
No deeper,
Yo,
I'm not going to sit around and meditate.
That's what it seems like you're trying to avoid.
Yeah.
And also I think that the,
the understanding of the broad concept is more important than the then the
minutiae.
Yeah.
You got to understand the details.
Yes.
But you won't understand the broad concept and then you can move forward and you
know what you're dealing with.
Yeah.
And then an academic type,
as we,
as the example,
as your example talks about,
like they'll,
they're kind of goal is,
is the thought has to analyzing it.
We'll see how this works.
And that's the whole goal.
Their goal is never really to take action.
Someone else can take action,
but there their goal is the thought of it.
That's what it seems.
I think that's one thing that Dan Carlin from hardcore history does is he,
so he like a lot of times I'm comparing what I'm reading about in his historical
situations to what I've either been through myself or,
or other books that I've read,
other situations I know about Dan Carlin does one book to another book or one
time to another time.
But then the other thing that he does is he takes it to us.
Like he'll,
he'll say,
imagine if you were,
imagine if America right now elected a person to keep,
so he brings it into like real time.
Yeah.
That's his,
that's his,
to me,
that's what makes,
that's part of what makes as long things that make his podcast excellent.
But that's one of the things that makes it very engaging as he brings it to
imagine if this happened today,
imagine if the Germans attacked,
you know,
he just brings it to today.
So it makes you think about it.
Andy compares it to other time periods.
So there's some similarities there,
but his thoughts aren't as ames.
Yeah,
I don't think.
Yeah.
And I wouldn't even,
well I think,
I think when I just said that I think he takes the thoughts and applies them to
current times.
Right.
That's what makes it interesting.
Or one of,
again,
one of the things that makes an interesting.
Yeah.
And I wouldn't even say be the thoughts being your aims is necessarily a bad
thing across the board.
Um,
I think,
you know,
obviously his approach it is,
but you know,
you know the person who's just kind of get the huge payoff in figuring out how
things work.
And that's Sorta it,
you know,
like kind of like,
hey,
if I,
I'm a,
you know,
I'm going to figure out how this,
I don't know this engine motor works,
it's up to the engine builder to build more engines or to build a better and
yeah,
they're just really interested in how things work,
you know?
Yeah.
Is it possible to be super,
you don't like people that want to understand Jujitsu,
but they don't want to do it?
The moves,
but they don't want to roll.
We'll there.
Is that for sure?
Oh yeah.
Is that,
and I mean depending on who you are,
obviously that philosophy won't kind of Jive with you with your whole thing.
Um,
but yeah,
I could see how that could be if someone's like,
yeah.
Like I don't know,
someone who's not into necessarily the physical part of it is much as the mental
part in maybe like the watch it.
And I suppose some guys that can't train hard anymore because of whatever they
got injured or whatever and they still are into it.
Well yeah.
Or these coaches that like maybe weren't getting good at something,
but they like,
they know then they're like the best coach and you know that kind of person.
Yeah.
John Danaher,
he doesn't have any world championships under his belt,
I don't think.
Yeah.
I Dunno.
But they would group Greg Jackson.
I don't think Greg Jackson,
you get Greg Jackson's never even fought MMA,
I don't think.
Not one time.
Yeah.
One of the best coaches,
coaches ever.
So yeah.
So you get that kind of person,
but would it be saying that he made his thoughts,
his aims?
No,
cause he put those,
he,
he applied them.
Yeah.
Well then again,
swinging a mess as academics though.
See what I'm saying?
Likely an academic type person,
maybe they're a professor or something they teach about business or sales.
They don't own a business,
their professor,
but they teach about business,
all this stuff.
So that's kind of,
it's kind of their,
their thoughts are,
their aims is kind of like that's their action.
That's,
that's they're putting their thoughts into action and if that's less of a shot
than maybe I read it as originally philosophers now.
All right,
well I think you're right.
I think you're right.
All right.
Next.
If you can meet with triumph and disaster and treat those two imposters just the
same,
what align that is
triumph and disasters and he calls them both imposters.
He calls both triumph and disaster calls them both imposters.
Why is that?
Because they are.
Because they are,
because neither triumph or disaster is an end all or be all neither of them.
They feel like it at the time.
When did you raise
your hands and you get the victory?
You feel like that is a be all end all.
But as patents said,
all glory is fleeting,
right.
That triumph is gonna fade.
Triumph is an eternal victory.
It's an imposter of one.
And this is what's important.
Does that,
and this is the one that's harder for people to overcome,
is that disasters the same way.
Some things happen to us and it seems like it's the end of the world.
Yeah.
Okay.
But it's not,
disaster is also an imposter.
This how you know what if this happens to,
this happens to teenage kids in their little relationships,
right?
Right.
Yeah.
Teenage kids and their love and the relationships.
They break off and they think it's the end of the world.
And if they only knew that in three years,
they wouldn't even remember that person's name.
You wouldn't even remember that person's name.
But you could never tell him that.
No,
you can't ever do.
Could you like that?
You couldn't convince them in a million years that,
that,
that in three years they will not remember that person's name?
No,
not even close.
Not even close.
You Care Doc.
Is it the mind?
The crazy thing,
you would have both know this factually.
Yeah.
The girlfriend that you had when you were 14 years old at that time,
there was no way that you were ever going to think about another girl.
That was the warning.
You don't eat right now.
You don't know what her name was.
You barely remember what she looks like.
Come on.
Yeah,
but that's what he's saying.
Yeah.
That when that girl breaks up with your guy,
if you're a,
if you're a girl and that good guy that broke your heart,
you're not even gonna remember this
and you know what he's doing now.
Not much.
Don't worry about that dude.
I don't know.
Maybe.
Yeah,
I guess that's a good point.
Maybe me.
Maybe it doesn't go
well.
It's the light point.
Most likely.
Yeah.
These disasters that you have and then you know UTC,
that's an easy one.
But you know your business has a big issue.
Yeah.
Oh,
it's going to man this.
Within six months of opening victory MMA,
the roof collapsed.
You remember that the drunk driver hit a fire hydrant out in front of the
building.
The fire hydrant actually broke off and the pipes just started squirting.
I mean how big around is up is a fire hydrant.
It's up eight 12 inches of water or something.
Oh what 12 inch waterline started spraying up and onto the top roof of the
building,
which is no big deal cause you know roofs are meant to take water.
Well what happened was the little drains cause it's a flat roof,
the little drains up there since it doesn't rain a lot in California they had
debris and they filled up the drains filled up and then the next thing you
don't,
the roof just filled with water inside the parapet wall and the roof collapsed.
That was in the six months of opening up.
I think we had just started making money.
Boom.
We got no,
we got half the building is gone.
The air conditioners from the second floor,
from the roof,
or on the bottom floor of the building in the mixed martial arts area that I
knew it was bad,
but you don't want to seem like a big disaster.
Guess what?
Get it.
Get it taken care of.
It's like,
move on.
Guess what?
The gym still 10 years old.
Still going strong.
Yeah.
So these bad things are gonna happen.
These disasters are going to happen,
but they're not permanent.
They're not the be all end all.
They're not the end of the world.
And the victories that triumphs are the same thing.
They're not going to last.
Don't rest on your laurels.
Stay centered.
Stay balanced.
It's the,
did you guys end up clearing out the drains are or what?
The drains.
Yeah,
we cleared them out.
Could I do a day late and a dollar short next?
If you can bear to hear the truth.
You've spoken twisted by Knaves to make a trap for fools.
So you're go out and you tell the truth.
Right?
And then the truth that you tell it gets
twisted around by some
nave,
which is an unscrupulous purse.
It's a to z dishonest first,
right?
Let's bring that word back.
It's bringing it,
they're going to twist your words and you're going to have to bear it.
And the reason that,
this is what I think is interesting,
the reason that you have to bear it is because if you get drawn into it,
it's a trap.
It's a trap that you're going to get drawn into if you start dealing with what
if you start going in and trying to,
trying to untwist this,
this lies that have been told about you and to trap.
That's what he's saying.
Hmm.
You,
it's almost like a battle you can't win.
And by entering the battlefield you're going to get one.
Yeah.
So what is this like some,
you know how like someone will say something Outta now and it'll like involve
race won't be racist but like involve race because that's how the explanation
pans out,
you know,
on TV or something.
And then someone else will come in and go,
oh my gosh,
this person's racist because look what he said.
And maybe they'll play like,
you know,
the end part of the tape only or the beginning only or something like that.
And then they'll,
someone else will be like,
hey,
you know this interview,
uh,
you know,
they'll ask this question,
hey did you say this?
And they'll be like,
well yeah,
I said that.
Oh it's,
and then someone else will come and be like,
look,
he even admitted he said this thing.
But then you know,
and then so that it just keeps getting twisted and twisted and twisted.
It's like that.
And then the more you explain it,
the mornings or,
wait,
you're saying you didn't say this and when no idea.
Okay,
well you did or you didn't kind of,
you know,
it's like that.
I think that's definitely part of it.
And probably
that's it.
I mean that,
When you go and try and unwind these things,
you're probably going to dig yourself a bigger hole.
I think that's the,
the overall,
yeah.
Yeah.
Could now,
are there times where people say something that's so horrible against you that
you have to defend yourself?
Sure.
That can happen.
I think when you do that,
you keep it simple.
You keep it direct and then you walk away,
right?
Yeah.
Did you look,
I would never have done that or I would never have said that or whatever.
And that's all I'm going to say.
Walk away.
Yeah,
break the wrist.
Walk away.
All right next.
Or watch the things you gave your life to broken and stoop and build 'em up with
worn out tools.
So you gave your life to whatever your life's work's.
You gave it all and it,
and that thing is broken.
It's destroyed.
And what you do is you stoop.
I like that word because what does that mean?
It means you're bending down.
That means you're bowing down,
right?
You're having to get down if to stoop down,
you go to the ground and begin to rebuild what has been destroyed and you do it
with worn out tools.
Now we're not just talking about worn out physical tools like a hammer and a
saw.
We're talking about,
you were talking about a worn out broken down.
You,
you are broken down and you're worn out,
but you go any way and you start from the beginning and you rebuild again.
That's legit.
Yeah,
the Game Contra,
no.
Okay.
There's this game on,
I don't even know what that Tyndale called.
Common Ground Nintendo won't.
Dang Bro,
that's too bad.
But there's this game named Contra and he knew who played Nintendo knows this
game cause freaking awesome.
It's this code is basically these two guys.
If you go one player,
you got one player to player,
two players play on the same screen and you just go,
it's like the basic side angle game.
These commando rambles guys side angle,
side angle.
Yeah.
It's not like,
you know,
instead of a first person shooter from it,
it's just a sighting.
And it's these Rambo guys,
he'd go to player,
they both play on the same screen,
boom against each other.
No with each other.
Okay,
so boom,
they kill bad guys.
Right?
So through the game you can get different weapons.
Okay.
So,
and each weapon is like more and more effective,
right?
So you can get the basic shooters.
What you start with and you have a machine gun,
you just hold the button down.
It goes any just machine gun.
Then there's like a laser that just geeking go and it can just kill like five
people in a row and there's,
then there's the spreader.
It's a spread gun.
So at a side,
a side angle,
game,
multilevel kind of thing.
The spread or he just kills everybody.
Boom,
boom.
So one,
if you kill,
can you kill your own personal accident?
No.
Google your bullets.
No,
no.
It's not realistic,
right?
This game is awful.
There are some unrealistic game.
There'd be some situations you get into bed,
teach you about combat.
Wouldn't teach you about the spreader.
Yeah.
What did he teach you about?
Blue on blue teach about fratricide.
All right.
Yeah,
it's about human loss.
Dig It in the,
probably be a heavy game,
but Tantra,
it's not like that.
So when you get to the point is the point is following me here.
The point is when you get to spread or you can make it super far because you're
just killing die.
If you have this infinite weapon,
well someone can still kill you.
If you mess,
you know,
someone shoots you.
It just like any other way you can die.
But since you have the spreader that's just killing everyone so easily,
you make it to high levels.
You see what I'm saying?
But here's the thing about concho.
When you get killed,
you get like you get three men,
right?
I know.
Unrealistic.
But still,
that's the most video games anyway.
You get three minutes.
If you get killed,
you lose the spreader.
You Start and you start again where you were,
but you still,
you get that pea shooter again,
the one you first started with.
So it's that same thing.
So you go through all the levels,
you work so hard to get.
The spreader we know is this,
you have three men,
three lives.
Here's the thing.
Yeah,
here's the,
okay.
The,
which is another thing about contrast,
which is so awesome.
You have three lives,
but if you know the code in the beginning of the game,
you can get 30 lives.
And here's the code up,
up,
down,
left,
right,
B a then press start.
That's the code.
It gives you 30 lives.
Everyone knows that I'll,
I will 100% guarantee that every single person,
every single person that has played contract and knows that code,
not even like 99% 100% cause you get 10 times the amount of effectiveness.
Yeah.
But it's a secret code.
It's not like it comes with a game like you got from any number of 100% of
people like 88 or 89 whenever that game was out.
Interwebs pre.
Yeah.
It'd be interesting to track how that information spread.
Back then,
back then,
how did it spread up?
Up,
down,
left,
left a,
B.
How did that spread on it?
You know there was no,
you wouldn't have got it.
There was no internet.
Yeah,
that's true.
No viable Internet.
Yeah,
that's true.
The kids for them sure were in on it.
I don't know.
But your point is that this taught you once yet.
We will use those worn out tools and he'll still try and go back and rebuild.
Contrast dye
is dead to not hear this.
I apologize if he understood the concept,
he'd be like,
you are exactly right because here's the thing,
here's the listen to the practicality of this over there
because with a spread,
okay,
if you just had the pea shooter,
right,
we'll call it the pea shooter.
That's the gun that you start with.
If you start with that,
it's really hard to make it to a high level because it's like the levels get
harder and harder and you just got that pea shooter but those guys are going to
kill you.
But if you get the spreader,
it's the exact opposite.
You can smash through levels and some of the levels at the end you got to have a
powerful weapon to beat the boss.
You see what I'm saying?
So if you have the spread or you can get pretty far what's,
I've heard people use the term boss is there,
is there a term called king boss or main boss or end boss?
Main bus and bus F for sure.
And this is a universal term maybe with video games.
Video Games.
Right.
And that's what my question bosses,
but we do,
we know where the,
the,
the term originated from the who is the original and boss.
There's a video that someone made that's really,
really funny.
It's called,
it's something about,
it's about me and it's,
it's a German guy and it's like how did Jocko Willink gets up massive.
I've used in that video.
What was it?
He just makes a video where he breaks down how I got so massive.
It's hilarious.
Yeah.
But one thing he goes,
this is the Ad Taco was the end boss to kill on them and I didn't really know
what to end boss was.
So I googled it and I figured out that it's when the video game,
world war in the boss,
do you remember the date of that?
Is it like an old school game?
Like a target or something?
No,
no,
no.
It's the video game world.
No,
no,
no.
The video games.
Yeah.
Got You.
Okay.
Do you are a little taken aback anyway.
Was this man world play that give him a spreader.
I'll go get some levels.
Cause they're called Kung Fu in original Nintendo is called come through five
levels but then they repeat and they get harder and hard.
But there's five levels and they'd I think in the game they called them the
boss.
Like the first level,
the second level blah.
I'm sure.
I'm sure there's cause there's other older game Boston on him nonetheless.
Well keep Linwood say because oh the point is when you get the spreader Kipling
you'll encounter when you get the spreader,
if you'll make it to a high level you will.
But here's the thing,
that high level is super hard.
So you need that spreader and if you get hit and you die when you know when you
come back to life or whatever,
you got the pea shooter,
you find yourself like this with worn out tools.
That's where you find yourself and it's hard and if you put your mind to it,
you can get that spread again.
But it's really hard.
Super hard.
Anyone who played concert hall will attest to that.
I think that right there is this,
we'll leave it at that man.
You know,
that's my recommendation.
All right.
Next.
If you can make one heap of all your winnings and risk it on a one turn of pitch
and toss and lose and start again at your beginnings and never breathe a word
about your loss.
Okay.
Never breathe a word about your loss,
isn't it?
When you meet someone and you,
you've talked to him and you deal with them for awhile and they don't tell you
anything about their background,
and then you find out later that they'd been through some big struggle,
so much more impactful and impressive.
Yeah.
Then when they're like,
Hey,
I did this and I went through at night,
you know,
just,
I got a good idea just to be quiet.
Don't breathe a word about your loss.
Yeah,
just move.
Just just perform.
Yeah,
and this is awesome about being willing to take risk,
willing to take risks.
This seems like an inappropriate risk to risk everything that you have on a
single turn of pitch and toss.
It doesn't seem like a smart risk.
Rudyard Kipling.
I don't know about that one.
Yeah,
take it.
I'm going to say
let's,
let's dial the dichotomy back of the extreme bedding situation.
Yeah.
Oh look at that being said,
you absolutely have to take risks in life,
right?
Like you gotta be something like a teeny tiny thing.
Gotta be a real risk,
no reward.
Well let's not risk everything in one turn of pitch and toss.
Let's not do that next.
If you can force your heart and nerve and sinew to serve your turn long after
they're gone.
And that's just awesome,
right?
We're talking about forcing your heart and your nerve and your one senior
basically means your tendons and your ligaments and the things that hold your
muscles and your bones together.
And you know who used Shakespeare used say knew quite a bit cause it just like
the core element.
But this is like saying you will get,
you will force your body and your mind to do what you need them to do.
Even when they're done,
they're done.
I'm going to force them to do more.
When they have nothing left to give,
you're going to force them to give anyways.
And then it rolls right into the next night,
the next night.
And so hold on.
When there is nothing in you except the will,
which says to them,
hold on,
got nothing left,
but we'll
force of will
to make it
okay.
Make them make,
make your heart a,
make your nerve,
make them hold the line.
If you can talk with crowds and keep your virtue or walk with kings,
nor lose the common touch.
So this is,
again,
this is staying balanced,
is the dichotomy.
No matter if you're involved with the masses,
right?
Even if you're involved with the masses,
you don't lose your virtue.
Or if you're rubbing elbows with the rich and powerful with the kings,
you don't lose that common touch.
You stay grounded.
You don't lose the ability to communicate with people up and down the chain of
command.
From a leadership perspective,
no matter what station someone is in life.
You remember,
remember episode five of this podcast,
I read a counseling letter to a good guy and I was like,
hey,
treat everyone respect.
Oh one or [inaudible] two o 10 like it doesn't matter what ranks and when does
he treat them with respect.
No matter what,
don't lose that
next if neither friends nor loving,
if either,
if neither foes nor loving friends can hurt you.
This is what's interesting.
It isn't always your enemies that hurts you.
Right?
In fact,
it's quite the opposite.
Usually the people that hurt you the most are the people that are closest to
you.
Those are the ones that really put the dagger in and twist it.
So you gotta be above that.
You got to,
you got to kind of insulate yourself from that.
You can't leave that last little bit of exposure,
in my opinion.
You gotta you gotta keep a little bit,
right?
You got to keep a little bit.
You got to keep up.
You gotta put yourself in a situation where you're not going to get crushed by
your foes or by the people that you're close to.
Yeah,
that's a hard,
I don't keep it inches.
It is hard.
Guys get jammed up.
Right?
The Echo Charles terminology that jams people up.
I'll find the,
the,
the enemy doesn't jam people up as bad as the,
the friends right.
Yet because the enemy expect that.
He expect,
I'm trying to jam you up,
but this goes back to the original,
uh,
what we talked about earlier,
the person,
and we've talked about this on the podcast,
the person that hurts you really bad,
that was your friend.
They weren't your friend.
Yeah.
They didn't exist.
The PR they,
you thought you knew them.
You thought you understood them,
you thought they were trustworthy.
They weren't.
So just we have to just look at it and say,
look,
that person that I was in love with or that person that I thought was going to
be with me all the time,
guess what?
That person doesn't exist so we got to move on.
So you've got to keep,
I think a little bit,
and this might sound cold blooded,
right?
It sounds a little bit cold blood.
It'd be like,
look man,
you got to keep it some stuff you gotta you gotta keep perspective.
You've got to keep people in check.
And if you let them get in to the point where they can grip you apart,
you're going to be careful.
Yeah.
Gotta be careful.
You decide you're going to do that with real careful.
Yeah.
Or you or this is,
I think what I do is more like this.
If that happens,
I recognize it.
Okay.
This,
this is what happened.
Boom.
That person wasn't who I thought they were.
We're moving on,
we're moving on next quest.
You know what I mean?
We'll move on on.
Yeah.
So I guess it may be,
I have the ability,
I shouldn't say that I have the ability,
I think I learned along the way.
Hey,
once someone exposes themselves,
reveals themselves as a,
as a nave
nave,
once they reveal themselves as a nave,
I'm over it.
I'm moving on cause I,
they've exposed,
they've revealed great.
I'm actually happy that now I don't have to invest any more time,
effort into this person.
That's a nave,
wretched nave nave.
Yeah.
And then you,
you have a kind of,
how should I say,
overdeveloped control of your emotions.
We'll call it where like the average person is like,
it's kind of like if you built a house right?
He built a house on coy and it was a nice house.
He lived there for 10 years,
15 years.
Even.
A lot of memories in that house.
Maybe even had some kids,
whatever,
first dog,
all that stuff,
and then a hurricane comes,
blows it down.
Right.
There's really nothing you could have done.
You know,
like if you had a girlfriend and then she doesn't have the signs of being a
nave,
but then maybe she changed.
Maybe she was that all along?
I don't know.
She'd be,
as it turns out,
Naif the house gets blown down.
Okay.
Girlfriend's gone.
You can easily say,
hey,
that was,
that wasn't the girl that I loved.
All this stuff.
Okay,
we're moving on.
Obviously you got to move on,
right?
She's an eighth yep.
If you're squared away in your head,
you got to move on.
You know that already,
but you can't just be like,
you're just move on.
What about all those memories?
The hurricane you talking about?
Both.
So yeah,
I'll go back to the hurricanes.
Memories.
Realize the mammoth nave.
The memories realize.
Yeah,
but yeah,
but emotionally it doesn't feel like you're free.
Okay,
so you got away Cape.
that's escaped the names.
That's good.
But you're talking about like how much you learned,
you learned that you gotta be careful.
Let's see what I'm saying though.
Like your sense of like emotional control allows you to go boom,
right.
Do that one.
Right.
And especially when it's fresh,
like you can't just,
Oh yeah,
I look how much I learned.
Yay,
let's get moving on that.
That's not the normal worse than norm poster person is.
It has still has opened wounds from,
because yesterday that house was intact and all the members to rebuild that
kitchen again.
I see what you're doing,
we'll see you doing it again.
You're just going straight to the positive thing,
which is a good thing to do,
which is the right thing to do.
But by the it capability wise,
the average person can't do that.
So no,
it's good.
Might be a little bit tricky,
but what are the options?
It will be a little more option.
There's no option.
Option is,
oh,
I'm going to be distressed and,
and mourn the loss of my house more than the loss of your house.
Do it for,
you know,
four days.
Yeah.
There should be a limitation.
Yeah,
that's a good idea,
huh?
Be like,
Hey,
one week.
Right now I'm going to just let my emotions just be my emotions.
Try not to like a week too long for a house for sure.
No,
that's,
that's one of the things that are for the girlfriend or for a girlfriend.
Yeah.
That's a bit rough.
People go months.
No.
People go years.
People talk about it for years.
That's not good.
That's what I'm saying.
That's,
that's too,
that's my point.
C instead of making me sound like I'm all cold blooded over here.
Well,
what you should say is like,
Hey,
I wish that some of the people that I know that wreck their lives over a
girlfriend,
boyfriend,
husband,
wife,
that broke up with him and they let it ruin their lives.
I wish you'd say,
Hey,
I wish that they would've had enough to emotional control to say,
you know what?
All right,
it's day three,
they're not coming back.
I have two choices.
Dig a hole.
Climate,
never come out or step up.
Make things happen.
You move forward.
The choice is obvious and once you step up and you start moving forward in three
years,
you don't remember that person's name anymore.
There are no factor.
Yeah,
you're no
factor.
Yeah,
man.
Yeah.
So what's the,
I mean obviously it's going to be depending on what kind of person it is.
So I've talked about this like we don't have a good,
a good system.
When someone dies in America,
we don't really know what to do because in other countries,
in other,
in other cultures,
they have a specific ritual that they go through.
And in America,
our rituals are kind of all jammed together and then we don't really know what
the right ritual is,
right?
We don't even know how to dispose the body.
Do we?
Do we burn it?
Do we bury it?
Do we buried at sea?
Like there's all these options.
Do you donate your organs?
Do you not either.
There's this like,
do you donate to your body to science?
Well,
what do we,
what are you supposed to do?
What's the right thing to do?
We don't even know that we would know what to do with someone's body.
So how are we supposed to know what we're supposed to do emotionally when
someone dies?
What are we supposed to do?
We don't have a physical ritual to do.
So now what do we do?
And so this is the same thing.
Like there should be rules.
Hey,
like a protocol.
It's a protocol broke up with significant other.
Here's the protocol.
Yeah.
One day.
Morning one pizza,
extra cheese.
Pepperoni sausage,
right.
Mint chocolate chip milkshake.
Sure.
Cool.
Next Day.
But no,
no,
but I don't recommend it.
I don't either because it'll go even more direction.
Yeah.
The next day I was like,
what I was going to say is like,
I was going to say eight mile run,
eight mile run.
That's just what you got here.
Yeah.
Hey.
Oh,
I bet.
Yeah.
What are you doing today?
Oh yeah.
I would have broke up my girlfriend two days ago.
I got rid of the miles tomorrow.
That's part of the protocol.
Yeah.
Oh,
you,
oh you,
oh.
And there can be different levels.
Oh,
I was going out with her for every,
let's say for every three months that you were with her.
That's one mile and mile.
Okay.
Yeah.
Good.
And so then you do that and we get done with that.
Guess what you gotta do you gotta do you gotta do what?
A contrast baths.
Ice Hot ice.
Hot New.
You got to do that four times,
right?
Yeah.
No.
What you do is this a good protocol for,
for a contrast baths,
five minutes,
ice,
four minutes,
ice form.
He go back and forth.
When you get done with that,
boom,
you come out,
you're cleansed.
And then guess what?
24 hour fast,
right?
24 hour fitness that he actually kind of sounds weird like for a breakup,
but boat,
so many cultures do that.
Oh yeah,
you've got to fast.
You can get a fast for this.
So and so.
Then we could go on and on,
but you make a protocol.
It's a three day protocol generally.
And then boom,
now we come out of that protocol and then there's one last,
the last thing on the protocol is like go to work or you know,
begin normal routine.
Back to normal routine.
You go to bed,
back to,
oh I know the final protocols.
Wake up.
Whatever time it is you get up in the morning.
Third,
fourth day.
Now the protocol has been completed.
Fourth Day,
boom,
wake up,
get,
get busy,
get on with it,
get after it.
That's what I'm talking about.
So we don't have that.
So if you,
if you put in your mind,
I think for me,
I recognize when something is dragging me,
this is dragging me in the wrong direction.
As soon as I see something dragging me in the wrong direction,
I know like a internal protocol.
It's like,
okay,
I'm emotionally attached to this situation.
It's not beneficial to me.
It's not going to help me.
It's not gonna help you understand the nature of the world's not gonna help me
move forward with my life is not gonna help me in any way.
Guess I'm gonna do,
I'm gonna Detach when I'm going to take a little step away from that thing.
Yeah.
Because I'm not saying emotions are bad,
emotions are great.
That's what makes us human beings.
Right.
I get emotional on this podcast.
Right?
Sure.
That's not bad.
No,
that's actually good.
Makes me understand myself and other things in the world better.
But that's a positive effect of emotions.
But if I start having negative emotions and they start dragging me down,
protocol,
execute the protocol,
boom.
That's what we need to do.
Yeah.
Like what if like part of the protocol was like to shave your head or something,
right?
Yeah,
for sure.
Yeah.
Like that could be right.
And then let's say like you,
you break up with your girlfriend or something and then like,
you know,
a few days later you see her at the post office.
I'm,
she has a shaved head.
You're like,
aw man,
she's getting over me quick.
You know what I'm saying?
Yeah,
but that would help though.
That would totally would because it's like,
it's like the,
it's like the process and it gives you something else to focus on.
See what I'm saying?
So it's like,
okay,
I know I'm talking about the protocol and Joe to call it a protocol.
Especially if it expands like,
you know,
three,
four days,
boom,
boom.
It's like,
you know,
it doesn't Aa have something like that to where you do the steps and protocols,
all kinds of things.
There's a reason protocols exist because it gives you something to follow.
You don't have to think about it and it moves you in the right direction.
Yeah.
So think about that for your life.
Pay attention to it.
Cause the scary part about this,
and we've talked about this too,
it's like the storm,
your head's in a storm and you can't get out and doing only person.
Everyone else can see that.
Your head has a,
has a,
has a two foot cloud around it and everybody can see if you just moving to a
direction,
you'll get away from that cloud.
But everywhere you look,
you just see storm is cloud and thunder and lightning.
So you don't think there's any way out.
But there is try to execute the protocol.
The protocol is you go do north 1800 meters,
you're going to be out,
right?
That's what's gonna happen.
Shave your head,
run eight miles,
eat a pizza,
eat a mint chocolate chip mug.
Milkshake.
That's day one.
That's a little comfort.
Little luxury.
Theo von luxury style.
All right,
next
we went way off on that one Bruh.
That was good.
That was actually really good.
That kind of gets you thinking.
Cause if you,
you could even do this right now if you're in,
even if you're in a relief,
even if you're not even in a relationship yet,
cause those are the call just yet.
Prepare a protocol like hey if this,
cause it's Kinda like a natural disaster.
You do that.
You know what?
There's also,
there's also something you could do that would be helpful and I hate to use this
word because it gets used in a different sense these days,
but you could have trigger points,
right?
Things that
happen where if you see,
if you identify things happening,
you go,
okay,
if I get involved in this situation and this happens,
that's a trigger.
That means I need to walk.
Right.
For instance,
let's say you have someone that has,
let's say,
let's say you meet someone that was an addict of some kind on alcoholic and
you're like,
okay,
if this person starts drinking,
that's my trigger,
I'm going to walk because you don't want to go down that spiral with them,
right.
Or whatever the case may be.
You have someone that used to date some other guy
[inaudible]
like,
hey,
if I see that there's whatever,
a Facebook connection,
again,
some walking,
whatever,
like you gotta yeah,
you figure out these things and that way you predetermine them when you're in a
nonemotional state.
When you get to the emotional state,
hopefully you can overcome your emotions.
Cause there's people who are like,
I don't care.
I love,
I love her.
I'm just going to keep going.
There's only this one time.
Right.
That's how she friended me.
And then they stick around.
But if you have your protocol in place,
if you have the triggers to execute upon,
it's going to make it easier for you.
It should make it easy for you.
Hmm.
All right.
Next one.
This is a good one if all men count with you,
but none too much.
And think about this.
When we actually got wrapped around this one a little bit in the podcast one
time.
Okay.
Because this is a dichotomy of the fact that I personally,
okay,
there's part of me that doesn't care what anyone thinks.
And then there's part of me that completely cares about what people,
specifically people that I have a lot of respect for.
I care what they think of a lot and people that I don't respect,
I don't care what they think.
So there's a dichotomy there.
And that's similar to what is being said here.
If all men count with you.
So you take their opinions,
you understand,
but at the same time,
none too much.
Yeah.
To sway you from the path.
And here next line,
I think he's one of the greatest minds.
Debit,
if you can kill,
if you can feel the unforgiving minute with 60 seconds worth of distance run.
So
the unforgiving minute,
that's a great,
that's the way you should think of every minute,
every minute that exists for you is unforgiving because it does not stop.
It does not forgive and you can't have it back.
That's the unforgiving minute time has no mercy on anyone.
Okay?
And what he's saying here is if you can feel every one of those unforgiving
minutes of your life,
every single one of them with a full 60 seconds of you running and moving
forward and getting after it,
if you can push that hard,
you can push that hard.
Then he closes out.
Yours is the earth and everything that's in it and which is
you'll be a man,
my son.
So there it is.
If you can do all those things,
and that's the name of the poem.
If,
if you can do those things,
those things that are simple but not easy,
easy,
simple,
but definitely not easy,
then the world will be yours and you will be a man meant in the most positive
possible way.
So now we go back.
This is what we do.
Now that we understand it fully,
we go through it fully.
Here it goes.
If,
if you can keep your head
when all about you are losing theirs and blaming it on you,
if you can trust yourself when all men doubt you but make allowance for their
doubting too.
If you can wait and not be tired by waiting or being lied about,
don't deal in lies or being hated.
Don't give way to hating and yet don't look too good nor talk too wise
if you can dream and not make dreams your master.
If you can think and not make thoughts,
your aim.
If you can meet with triumph and disaster and treat those two imposters just the
same.
If you can bear to hear the truth,
you've spoken twisted by Knaves to make a trap for fools or watch the things you
gave your life to broken
and stoop and build them up with worn out tools.
If you can make one heap of all your winnings and risk it on one turn of pitch
and toss and lose and start again at your beginnings and never breathe a word
about your loss.
Okay.
If you can force your heart and nerve and sinew to serve your turn long after
they are gone.
And so hold on.
When there is nothing in you except the will,
which says to them,
hold on.
If you can talk with crowds and keep your virtue.
Yeah.
Or Walk with kings,
nor lose the common touch.
If neither foes nor loving friends can hurt you,
if all men count with you,
but none too much.
If you can feel the unforgiving minute with 60 seconds worth of distance run,
yours is the earth and everything that's in it
and which is more,
you'll be a man,
my son.
And there you have it.
Some pretty straightforward instructions from Kipling on how to live.
And I looked at it and his son died in world war one.
He wrote this poem just before the turn of the century.
So he wrote this poem before his son was killed before his son went to warm,
perhaps just after his son was born in that timeframe.
Ah.
So I'm sure his son grew up with these thoughts
and I think it's thoughts that we can all use.
So [inaudible] thank you.
And now we are going to go through some Q and a dig into a little bit of Q and.
A.
Okay.
Echo Charles [inaudible].
First question.
First question,
Dave.
Jocko,
many times he said that liking a fight or liking to fight should be a part of
every man's personality.
Could you expand on that?
I've always been interested in martial arts,
but I've always been reluctant to fight and I would do anything not to.
Does that make me less of a man?
So obviously this is a pretty fitting question for the situation.
Yeah.
So this is obviously a good question.
Uh,
and a fitting question.
Talking about being a man.
Uh,
I don't know if I said liking to fight should be a part of everybody's every
man's personality or if I said that it is part of every man's personality edit I
think I said is part of their personality.
And if I said that,
what I,
I think I should've said is most right,
most men have in their personality some level of interest of fighting,
right?
We wrestle,
we box,
we scrapped his kids.
Look at the UFC.
Breck,
why is the UFC so popular right now?
Because it's fighting and we have that.
That's a,
I read the other,
that's a $7 billion organization.
That's a,
there's a lot of people watching those fights.
A lot of people want to watch those fights.
We have boxing,
we have wrestling,
we have Jiu Jitsu,
we have judo,
we have moy,
Tai.
We had all kinds of martial arts schools.
So while I don't think the desire to fight is inherent in all men,
right?
I'm sure there's men out there that are not into it at all.
But I think it's definitely a pretty strong part of many men.
Now for this individual,
particular,
um,
I do,
do I that being reluctant to fight makes you less women?
No,
actually I think it's fine.
The,
you should be reluctant to fight.
I think everyone should be reluctant.
There's a lot of bad things that can happen in a fight.
A lot of bad things.
You know,
first of all,
you can get hurt,
right?
That's bad.
You can get seriously hurt.
You can get killed,
you can get killed,
you can get punched one time,
fall down,
hit a curb and die.
You can think you're going to get in a fair fight with someone.
They can stab you in the neck and kill you.
Right?
These things can happen.
Even if it's not that bad,
you can hurt someone else.
Now you're getting lawsuit,
now you're getting put in prison.
Right?
So there's all kinds of bad things.
So being reluctant to fight is actually a good thing.
And it's something that men should have.
And actually the more you know about fighting,
the more reluctant you will be.
I was way the less I knew in my life about fighting the more,
or sorry,
the more I actually knew about fighting,
the more reluctant I became to fight cause I realized all the risks that are
involved.
Part of that was maturity.
Sure.
But the reality is you look at someone and you go,
Ha,
I don't know who that person is.
A they,
they might be training.
I'm over here thinking I betrayed him Jujitsu for eight months.
I'm ready to kick this guy's ass.
Meanwhile,
you don't know that guy as a purple belt.
Guess what's going to happen to you?
You're getting crushed.
Or that guy wrestled in high school,
he's about to double leg.
You can slam you on a curb,
you're going to die.
So you should be reluctant to fight.
That's a good thing.
Now that being said,
I do recommend that you are prepared to fight.
I definitely recommend that and there's going to be a big dichotomy here.
I'm going to get to,
but you should know some basics,
right?
You should understand threats.
You should know how to contend with other people.
You should.
You know you should know some boxing.
You should know some rescue.
You should know some words.
I should know some Jujitsu for sure
because here's the dichotomy.
This is the,
this is a big dichotomy and think about it.
It's 100% true.
This,
this individual says he would do anything not to fight,
would do anything not to fight.
Let me tell you the best thing you can do as a human so that you don't have to
fight is actually learned how to fight.
That is the best way to not have to fight as if you know how to fight.
If you know how to fight,
people aren't going to want to fight you.
You don't even have to say anything.
They can tell.
You can tell when you meet somebody.
You can tell if that person,
oh,
if you,
if you're ready to fight,
people don't want to fight you.
The more eager you are to fight,
the less people want to fight you.
If you don't know how to fight and and bullies,
because that's what we're talking about.
Bullies see that you don't want to fight.
Guess who they're coming after.
You now guess what?
Now you have to fight,
but if you know how to fight and you have that confidence and you have that
understanding and you learn simple things like avoidance and you learned,
you have better situational awareness,
you become a threat to the people that want to fight you.
You become a threat to them just by just by your knowledge alone.
So no,
not less of a man
because you were elected to fight.
You actually should be reluctant to fight,
but you should learn how to fight because the best way to avoid fighting,
the more equipped and prepared to fight you are,
the less you will have to fight,
the less you will be put in positions where you have to fight and the better the
outcome will be if it does happen to occur.
Yeah.
Interestingly,
like a lot of the people that you meet in Jujitsu or just like this where I'm
interested in martial arts,
but I'm not interested in fighting.
No,
but for sure,
for sure,
and then they learn it.
Then I get all of,
there's a strong component of nerds in Jujitsu,
right.
Strong component.
Really strong of of,
you know I'm saying it jokingly,
but there's just a studious type students per type people that aren't super
physical.
They're more cerebral than they are physical.
There's a ton of people like that.
And you know what,
they'll do choke you out.
They wind up being real good.
Yeah.
They wind up being real good cause they like Oh I I understand this.
There's a,
this is a game that I can learn and I can crush and that's good and now I have
more conference on her for worry about it anymore.
Again.
It's interesting how that third or that,
that additional element that they're not really used to like how you say nerds
and you know,
we'll just say like people who are more cerebral within physical,
it's that maybe they didn't play high school sports.
Right?
Yeah.
Cause they were working on a computer.
Right.
Cool.
Right on.
Yeah.
They were playing music,
right?
Yeah.
Whatever.
And then now they get into this highly physical situation cause just to,
let's face it,
it's physical.
That's your whole body.
It is physical as can be and but you get in it and you're just finding success
just by learning it.
It's not like football where it's like,
sure,
I know how to catch.
I can't run fast though and I can't.
I'm not big and strong or whatever,
so I'm just getting smashed.
But this,
it's kind of like the more you know,
the better you are kind of thing and sure.
Physical attributes help you.
For sure buddy.
That is,
there's,
there's you being stronger is great.
Yeah.
You know,
Dean was talking about the city on the map.
The stronger guys not always going to win.
The more athletic guys not always going to win.
Sometimes they do.
There's various categories that will bring you a victory.
One of the strongest categories that you can have.
Well,
this strong,
the strongest category is your technique is knowing what to do because no one
wants to do.
And so you're smart people,
your cerebral people that come in and go,
oh,
I can apply.
I can apply this knowledge.
The same way I applied my skills in accounting.
James Nielsen,
world's toughest accountant.
He's an accountant,
he's a backs.
So that's just the reality.
And yet,
and that's why,
so now they're,
that's why people get addicted to,
because it's like this element of physicality,
like a physical fighting,
more fighting sport by the way,
combat sport.
And now they're in the Ed and they're good at,
they're good at something physical for the first time and they're still smart as
smart can be,
you know,
like they always were.
So now they got that and that
additional,
um,
like pay off,
you know,
that's where they get it to district power.
Yeah.
I recognize that with kids that come to Jujitsu,
the oftentimes,
and it's not an always,
oftentimes the kids that get really into Jujitsu are kids that are smart and,
but they haven't done a lot of other sports yet.
And it's exactly what you're saying you'd,
it's very noticeable with kids.
The kid that played baseball his whole life and he comes in there,
he actually doesn't like it at first and maybe doesn't even want to do it
because he's getting choked by someone that seems all nerdy to him.
Yeah.
And he knows I could throw a baseball farther than this guy.
And so it makes him mad and he doesn't want to train.
Yeah.
But oftentimes it's the kids that come in that really haven't done too much
athletically and you know,
they're,
they got picked on.
We got,
we've,
I've had a lot of bullies come to my Jujitsu kids program.
The reason they're there is because they got bullied and once they started
training six months,
they're not getting bullied anymore.
And a year later they're a different person.
There are different kid,
confident,
assured themselves not backing down,
not being jerks,
not being bullies themselves,
but just confident.
Hmm.
So yeah,
transferred.
You get to dot.
All right.
Next question Jocko and echo question.
How important is personal intelligence in the military,
particularly in,
in more dangerous roles as compared to physical strength?
I'm a college student who will probably go to ocs,
ocs,
officer candidate school.
Yeah.
So this has been on my mind.
Well,
okay,
so intelligence is paramount,
right?
Of course.
If you aren't smart that you're going to do dumb things and dumb things can
definitely get you killed.
This is not to say that if you do dumb things,
you will get killed.
Cause I did some really dumb things,
aid,
combat and I didn't get killed.
And it certainly isn't to say that if you get killed,
you did something dumb because to combat it has no mercy and you can be the best
trained,
the smartest,
the most tactful sound person in the world.
And those people can still get killed.
Combat doesn't care about any of that.
That bullet has no one's name on it.
It the bomb has no one's name on it.
It's going to go off and it's going to take out who it takes out and that's
that.
But as far as weighing,
you know,
intelligence and cognitive power versus strength,
I mean you have to be,
I mean I would rather be smart and being smart is very important because if
you're smart,
if you aren't smart,
I should say you,
you increase your chance of doing something that isn't smart and then you're
going to make some kind of mistake that will negatively impact you.
So yes,
being smart is very important.
Now
there are some cases without question where physical strength and stamina is at
least as important and sometimes more important.
Hm.
That's just the way it is.
You might have to climb a cliff to escape the enemy.
You might have to Mike Thornton,
Mike Borton swam for what,
five hours dragging two people.
Now he could be the smartest guy in the world and which he did a damn good job
of,
you know,
getting the life jackets and getting him a self,
organizing a situation where it'd be the easiest possible way for him to swim.
Even with that,
you still got to swim for five hours dragging to people while you're wounded,
by the way.
So if he didn't have that physical strength at that point,
that brain Borden matter,
it wouldn't matter.
So what's interesting about this is guess what a really smart person will get
himself or herself,
the physical capabilities,
that's what you'll do.
The smart person,
they're really smart person will work their ass off to get in shape and in to
stay in shape.
Because you can be smarter to come up with the most brilliant plan in the world.
But if you don't have the physical where we fall to execute that plan and that,
that brilliant plan doesn't matter.
So yes,
you want to be smart and yes,
you want to be fiscally strong.
You want to exercise your brain and your body as much as possible and get them
both as mentally strong,
physically.
Get yourself as mentally strong,
as physically strong as you possibly can.
And that's not just in the,
not just in the military,
that's in life
life.
Somebody quoted on Twitter the other day,
you,
you to,
you can't,
you don't know.
Two plus two if you're dead,
you can't add two plus two.
So if you're,
if you're investing all your time in being smart or you're investing all your
time and in that intellectual aspect of your life,
and then you let your physical aspect go,
yeah,
well guess what?
Now you're now you're unhealthy.
Now you die because you didn't take care of you.
Now what good is your brain now?
Zero.
Good,
good check.
Next question.
[inaudible].
How do you give feedback to someone without everyone taking it personal?
I tried to give criticism regarding their work or actions while not attacking
their character,
but unfortunately many feel that it's personal.
Yeah,
welcome to the world.
People don't like Chrisholm criticism and I almost put eight,
no one in the world likes crypsis.
Okay,
so there might be 1e-05% of the world that's really like open and ready for
feedback.
Right?
But most people,
even when they say,
even when they tell you they want feedback,
they don't want it.
They don't want it.
Like,
let me,
let me give an example.
If you echo Charles,
yes,
we're like you,
you made a video and it took you hours.
Don't even don't even right.
You know what I'm saying?
Like you could come to me and say,
Hey,
what do you think?
You know?
And I was like,
well,
you know,
I think you framed this up wrong.
How?
What's your reaction to that?
I mean there's no possible way that you're stoked on that.
Now,
luckily,
you know,
we know each other.
You can detach and be like,
all right,
I need to,
he's,
he doesn't,
he's not pointing this out to me for no reason,
whatever.
But what I'm saying is even when you're saying,
Hey,
what do you think of this?
And I criticize something that you work so hard on,
there's no one in the world that's happy about that even when they ask for it.
So you have to flank people.
That's what you have to do.
Now he's asking specifically,
how do you do this?
So here's some things.
What one of the things that I do when I want to give someone criticism,
I don't give him criticism.
What I do is I ask them questions about whatever it is.
Now this is interesting.
I'm not even talking about pointed questions.
I'm not even talking about like hard questions.
I'm talking.
I'm not saying like,
why did you do that?
I'm talking about,
hey,
why did you do it that way?
There's a big difference between like,
hey,
why did you do it that way?
I mean like instead of saying,
Hey,
echo,
that frame is doesn't look good.
Hey,
why'd you frame that up like that?
Right?
So now I'm getting you to think about it,
right?
But I'm not going to say,
how are you going to make that work?
You know,
I'm going to say,
well,
hey dude,
do you think are going be able to make that work?
If you did something and it doesn't go well,
I'm not going to say,
you know,
did you actually think that was a good idea?
Instead,
I'm going to say it's,
again,
it's not pointed question.
I'm going to say,
well,
hey,
did that unfold the way you thought it was going to unfold and now you're going
to get to answer the question.
Now you're going to be,
you're going to be the person that uncovers the fault.
It's going to be you,
not me.
And that makes it so much more palatable to everyone when they're able to say,
oh yeah,
you know,
I saw this over here,
and most of the time the person knows the truth.
Most of the time the person knows that that thing's not framed up right.
They know that their idea wasn't not great.
So you don't need to punch them in the face with it cause that's actually going
to make them get defensive.
So you flank them,
you ask them the questions,
you talk about it,
you discuss this subject and what you do is you guide them,
you guide them to a mirror,
you guide them to a mirror and then,
and then you just have a look in that mirror.
You set them up.
So they have to look in that mirror so that they can see the problems
themselves.
And once they see the problems themselves,
they can start to correct them.
Now sometimes you,
sometimes it's your ego
that wants,
even once they see the problem themselves,
do people want them to take credit for showing that and this leads and so you
gotta,
you gotta check your ego.
You've got to make sure that your ego isn't saying,
I want to prove to this person that I know how to frame this up better than
you've got to put that all in check.
And you've got to just let you gotta let them have it.
So,
and now,
are there situations where you can give really good frank feedback?
Yes there is,
but you have to have a good relationship with that person or really good,
really good relationship with that person.
And the,
usually one of the best ways to,
to make this happen is that the feedback,
the negative feedback is going both ways.
Meaning I want to get negative feedback about my performance from that person so
that there's some equity nymity and what's being said amongst us.
Right.
So I might be low,
you know,
I might say,
hey echo,
hey man,
I,
you know,
I did this,
uh,
I answered this question on Qa.
Did you think that was a good answer?
Because I think,
you know,
I think could have been better.
And then you say,
yeah,
you know,
you dragged on and he talked too long and whatever,
you give me some critique and then I go,
oh yeah,
hey.
And by the way,
the lighting on that didn't look good.
Right?
And so now we have a little mutual criticism and it's all good.
It makes a little bit more palatable to you cause I made the thing.
And so that's sometimes works.
But what's interesting is even when you do that,
some people just don't even freaking care and they even after they just tear you
apart and then you throw a little little like a little nick on their shoulder,
on their arm,
you give him a little nick about something that wasn't right.
They still get.
So you have to be really,
you have to have a really great relationship with that person to be able to have
just that straight,
straight feedback.
But build relationships,
ask them questions,
let them find their own fault if you can,
and be their guide.
Let them,
guide them to that mirror,
guide them to their faults.
Now of course,
there are some people that won't even find their own faults,
no matter how you guide them in how hard you try and twist them to look in the
mirror.
You have to let them know you actually have to come out and say,
what's going on?
You have to be more direct.
Now,
luckily,
if a person is the type of person that fails to see their own faults,
they begin to fail,
right?
Because they're making mistakes.
That's why their faults,
right?
They're making mistakes.
And when they see that,
when you see that and you see that their project is failing,
or you see that there are people are revolting against them or you see that
they're missing deadline after deadline,
they know that too.
And then what you're doing is you're coming to them basically as like a
concerned friend that really wants to help them win.
And,
and pointing out some of these obvious failures that they might not be aware of
and you still gotta be gentle about this.
But when you come to them,
you can come to them as a friend,
as a,
as a person that really wants them to win.
And you can come out out of there looking like the good guy trying to help them
get there,
their self back on track.
So those are some of the,
some of the basic strategies.
And I used to help people do a little course correction if people need a little
criticism.
So that they can,
uh,
improve their game for themselves,
for the team,
et Cetera.
Good
businessman.
My input.
People aren't be part people don't like criticism.
Yeah.
Here to tell you.
They like praise.
You know how,
and you know the other side of this coin,
if you're a person,
which you are and you don't like criticism,
which you don't,
if you can open your mind to the criticism,
man,
you're already going to be.
So you're going to get so much better about everything that you do.
If you can just listen to people without getting ego crazy and thinking about
this
and just listen,
just listen.
Nod your head less than what they have to say.
They're trying to help you.
Right.
We assume that they're trying to help us.
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
Are there times when they're not?
Absolutely.
Yeah.
Cause you know,
you can go in with the assumption that this person just tried to cut me down.
Well then that's not going to get you anywhere.
But if you're,
if you make the assumption,
you know what,
I'm going to listen to what this person has to say,
what's wrong with that?
Yeah.
Even if it's an assumption and we're not supposed to assume,
if I assume anyone,
I'm going assume that echo has given me criticism right now because he wants me
to do better and I'm going to take them as as face value as I can that he is
trying to help me get better.
Yeah,
boom.
Yeah.
And yeah,
that's actually really correct.
If you start at that point,
that's your default,
right?
Hey,
this is to help.
Now I might look at your criticism and I analyze it from a detached perspective
and I go,
I think actually echo is just trying to drag me in the wrong direction because
he's jealous and I might get to that point.
Yeah.
And it'll be more way more obvious.
It'd be way more often if you started at that other points where it's like,
okay,
it's here,
but if you're just default all he just wants to try to look like he knows
everything or he just wants to,
you know,
make it,
you started their place to be.
Yeah,
you can't even kind of discern,
you know,
if that really is happening or not.
Not the place to be.
Next question,
Choco.
What's the best way to combine striking and grappling with self defense in mind?
Never heard you mentioned MMA in this context,
only Jujitsu with gloves on.
Consequently,
how the team's adept MMA based training to real situations.
What's your take on armies?
Modern Army combat.
It's okay,
so a few questions there.
How do you best learn to combine striking and grappling?
Well,
what you do is you combine striking and grappling.
That's how you get good at it.
You put on the big gloves,
we used to call it shoot boxing.
That was like a block of training that we doing with with guys that were
fighting MMA.
You put on the big relatively big boxing gloves and then you put,
you mix and take downs with them.
So that's great.
You should do that.
You can do that with kids too.
You can do that with kids where you put the big boxing gloves on kids and you
have him shoot those double legs all day long so that when somebody takes a
swing at them,
they know how to set up,
they know the timing,
they start to get familiar with it because in a way,
well it takedowns are easier in MMA because the person is not solely defending
against a takedown.
They're defending against punches,
they're defending against kicks.
So they have to be in a different
stance.
Yeah.
And so that's the way it works.
Um,
if you want to train to get combined striking grappling,
you have to combine them together.
And you know,
if I've only mentioned it with do you do to scrubs on,
man,
I've done a ton of MMA sparring with fighters,
like a ton with gloves,
with big gloves,
shoot boxing,
little gloves,
everything.
And I don't know why.
I haven't talked about it much,
but yeah,
I've done a ton of it.
And that's how I know like taking someone down with that's trying to punch you
is easier.
Uh,
now it sucks when you get punched.
No,
but it is easier than going against someone that's just trying to wrestle you
and has a different stance on lower stance and all that.
So yeah.
Um,
that's how you do it.
You put,
you put,
you put big gloves on and then also you can do,
you can drill with big gloves on where someone was trying to punch you while
they're in your guard oil while you're punching,
while someone's trying to punch you while they're mounted.
You can do that with slaps too,
right?
Like I mount you and I'm just start slapping you.
Cause then you realize if these were punches you'd be in serious trouble.
Yeah.
So yeah,
you can mix those things in and mix them together.
Don't get hurt.
Be careful.
But yeah,
you can definitely make some.
So now the next question was how do the teams adapt to MMA back based trainings
as well.
The big concepts are the same.
The big concepts are exactly the same.
You're going to have to close the distance.
Like if you've got someone that's unarmed that you're gonna need to get control
of,
well you got to close the distance.
You've got to take him down,
you've got to get control of them.
You've got to submit him or subdue him somehow that that can happen.
You've got to be able to break away.
If somebody grabs you,
you've got to be able to break away.
You've got to be able to get up off the ground.
There's some large muscle movements that are exactly the same.
The striking parts are exactly the same.
Someone's,
you know,
you want to clear someone or or,
or you want to punch someone to get them,
you know,
a little bit dis disoriented before you get controlling.
Yeah,
that's,
that's what you're doing.
That's what,
that's what boxing is,
you know,
and so those things aren't the,
there's so much of it that overlaps that the adaption doesn't have to be barely
anything.
The adaption comes in and we have to do some additional training,
some additional concepts.
Is that you're moving with Iran,
that you have to be able to protect your weapons and your weapon systems.
So you,
you know,
you want to be aware of where your rifle is,
where your pistol is,
where your knife is,
so that people can't get ahold of it.
Mm.
Weapons retention.
So that becomes part of it.
The,
the,
the fact that you're working with another person,
usually a partner,
a shooting buddy that's [inaudible],
that's gonna cover move for you.
So if I go to take a guy down,
I got to be aware of where my partner is in case that person that I'm trying to
take down gets the upper hand or has a weapon that I didn't see so that my
partner can get a clear shot.
So there are tactical things that you do have to add in,
but the fundamental concepts,
there's,
there,
there are so transferable,
there's so transferable that it's,
it's,
it's like,
you know,
I,
it's a Gi and no GI,
right?
It's like,
Gee,
you know,
if someone is awesome at Ge,
they're going to be good at Nogi and will.
Are there some concepts that you need to learn?
Yeah,
there's some little things,
but there's an overlap is huge.
Baseball and softball,
right?
The,
if someone played college baseball and now they're playing on their local
restaurant softball team,
they're going to crush it,
right?
It's not the exact same sport.
Longboard Surfing Versus Short Board Surfing.
Right?
If someone's a great surfer on a short board,
they're going to be decent on a longboard.
They might,
they're not good.
They might not win the world champion.
Like if someone's awesome Nogi and they don't really train d,
they're not going to win the worlds,
but there'll be,
there'll be damn good.
One of the things that I used to,
well,
okay,
shooting,
you've got combat shooting,
but then you just have competitive target shooter.
Right?
Is competitive target shooting the same as combat shooting?
No.
There's no explosions.
There's no movement.
Or oftentimes,
I know there's,
there's competitions where they do a movement too,
and the more close it is,
the better it's going to be.
But if you're a competitive rifle shooter and you and then you do combat
shooting,
it is definitely,
there's a ton of crossover.
One of the things that I used to talk about a lot when people would question,
hey,
well MMA fighting as an ad,
it's not good for the seal teams cause you don't have any gear on.
One of the examples that I used a lot was guys that were really into
parachuting.
And you know when you,
when you jump in the civilian world,
you don't have a rucksack,
you don't have a weapon,
you don't have night vision goggles,
you don't have any of that stuff.
And yet if you have a thousand jumps as a civilian with a slick Reagan,
you're going to be infinitely better at the military.
Skydive with the,
with the weapon and the rucksack and the night vision and all that,
you're going to be infinitely better.
It's the same exact thing.
Are there some little things that you're gonna have to figure out some details
where that,
where they don't completely overlap?
Yes,
absolutely.
Um,
so there you go.
So I guess when you train Jujitsu,
wrestling,
boxing,
Muay Thai there,
if,
if you're in the military,
you know you also have to make sure that you carve out time where you think
about the other components,
right?
About beer having gear on and what that,
what changes when you have your gear on and how to protect your weapons.
All that stuff that I talked about and I would go about working with other
people about the tactical situations that you're in because there can be some
tackles situations that you're in.
If you're not thinking right,
you're going to have a problem you ever do you ever had somebody that goes well
did you do to smell good for self defense?
Cause what do you do?
Pull Garden the street.
It's like,
no,
you're never going to pull guard in the street or you shouldn't as if pulling
guard is like the only stuff.
But here's the be well the fact is if someone takes you down in the street and
you don't know the guard,
what are you going to do?
You're going to get your face smashed.
Yes sir.
So you got to cover both angles,
but there's so much overlap that if you get good at the fundamentals of MMA,
you will be really good at the what you need to know with the additional
concepts on military tactical takes type situations.
As far as modern army combatives,
it's a great solid foundational program and created by,
uh,
some great,
great,
uh,
martial artists that were in ground floor.
I think Matt Larson,
he's the guy that did kind of,
is the grandfather of forefather of,
I don't know if he's old enough to be grandfather.
He might even be my age still.
I Dunno.
It's not really bad.
But yeah,
I mean he put together a great system and it's a great fundamental system is
could someone pick apart some aspect of the army because I'm sure you could.
Yeah.
But you look at the whole system.
It's a great solid system.
Get people started out on,
so props,
I mean,
any system you can kind of say that for.
Yeah,
you can't,
you can't.
And that's why it's important to,
that's why I said foundational system,
right?
Because it's a great foundational system because once you learn it,
you don't,
you don't learn the Army combat the modern army combatives and then say,
okay,
well good,
now you don't need to train anymore.
That's not the right answer.
The right answer is you have a good foundation now keep building on it.
Yeah,
that's the answer.
Yeah.
I remember you train for MMA and pankration that
train for a while and the sparring element of it,
you know,
the three feet,
cause there's,
you know,
even if you're training MMA,
you're going to change striking one day and maybe even specialized striking
stuff one day.
And then you know,
wrestling and grappling and you do it through one day,
but you have MMA sparring,
which is a full MMA fight with big gloves and you know,
may or may not have shin pads or whatever,
but it's essentially MMA fight.
And that is 100% incorporating grappling and striking and take that.
It's everything,
you know.
So it was kinda like one of those things where you get to train to fill in those
gaps between,
okay,
one moment I'm striking.
One moment.
I'm grappling and the strikes while you grappling and there's,
and there's some,
there's some inconsistencies.
Cause if you were striking with big gloves then you can't grab someone's hands
the way you would with the little gloves on.
But you,
like you said,
what it does is it fills in the gaps.
Yeah.
So yeah,
the training,
that training is forced.
So like,
um,
you know,
if you're,
if you'd like to play guard or you have a slick game from garden or whatever,
if you train like an MMA training or training with strikes and stuff like that,
it'll really expose where you're in danger in a real fight because that guy's
gonna you know,
that guy's going to punch you in the face down a lot.
So it us,
it's a faster pace thing.
So it just builds your awareness of it.
So I remember that,
that even when I just go back to regular digits or whatever,
it's like,
man,
I feel super aware of it.
Like almost like you're anticipating,
okay,
I can get punched from you.
Actually think about that all the time.
Like I'll be rolling with Taylor and Chris Taylor is an like Andy,
I don't think about it as much because the Andes more of a Jujitsu fighter.
But you know,
Taylor,
he's an MMA fighter.
And so if he's on top of me for all round,
like he's in my top half guard and when we get done I'll be like,
I'm glad that wasn't him.
May cause you would pulverized in my head,
you know?
And now do some gaps open up when people start punching.
Yeah,
they do.
Yeah.
Is there an opportunity?
Yeah there is.
But you're going to take some shots.
Yeah.
Well,
and then at the end of the day,
all that is part of it,
you know?
So it's like if you're,
if you're,
okay,
so here's the scenario I'd find myself in where the guy I'm going to get to is a
way better striker than me.
Like way more experienced in just better,
but my Jujitsu is way better.
So it's like,
Dang,
I could get this guy to the ground.
So if we don't,
when we train this it,
I get that practice to be okay,
I'm gonna use this guys striking to like get around them or something like that.
I'm not going to like shine her and strike to strike with him and he'd beat up
this training session.
But you do have to stand there long enough to get them to think,
to get them to forget about you taking them down.
But yeah,
fully.
That's what I always,
and you'd see that in MMA fights too,
right?
You can't just go in there and start shooting on the guy because they know that
you're gonna try and take them down because they know their ground game is
worse.
And so they're going to defend that tech down.
Exactly right.
And get,
I'm thinking about,
you've got to get them thinking about that knockout that they're going to knock
you out.
And sometimes it takes two minutes,
sometimes it takes three minutes.
Sometimes it takes a round and a half before you take your first shot yet.
And really to be real with you,
it's,
that's what this training is for us.
So in the beginning you might not even be able to take that guy down because
he's like,
oh I know this guy.
He's that Jujitsu guy now he's going to train with us.
He was right.
Take me down and he's just going to beat you up from the outside.
And actually,
yeah,
what he'll do is he won't even beat you up.
He'll,
he won't even commit to his punches cause he doesn't want to overstep and,
and give you any advantage on your takedown.
Yeah.
So he'll just sounded like you said Sam,
the outsides of attacking you.
And I say that cause that's kind of what happened to me.
So I'd go in and then of course they just stay away or sprawl cause they know
it's coming kind of thing.
And then you know,
as you reset from the straw sprawl,
he'd put the one to kind of on the,
on the separation.
I don't read all that kind of stuff.
Yeah,
no big deal.
One to crack just all around.
No,
I'm saying it's funny because when you say,
you know,
you take a one,
two is you're getting away,
but that punches big boy.
Big Boy real.
Yeah.
But after a while,
that's what I'm saying.
You get that training just through the genie and like,
okay,
I know how this is.
No,
I can't.
It's not like Jujitsu where I can kind of,
you know,
just go and lock up and if I don't get to take the whole pull guard kind of
thing,
these guys,
they're not trying to grapple with you.
They're trying to send back up.
You get that training,
you know,
so when you wind up,
being able to take them down and all this stuff you can like,
you'll have just way more fun an advantage because you're aware of all these
different elements that you,
you might not get in just Jujitsu class.
You might get them,
but you probably probably don't.
You get a guy who always wants to stand up and Jujitsu class short.
We'll roll with a guy in Jujitsu just straight you just to,
who only wants to stand up who just would rather die than be in the bottom?
Hilstadt it's so annoying.
You know what I mean?
It's challenging.
It's something you need to learn to contend with because they are,
there are tactics that you can use as the guy on top to keep them down there.
Exactly right,
and you get MMA guys,
especially if you're better than them at like the Jujitsu element of it.
That's what they're going to do.
So that's the training you're going to get.
Chuck Jocko,
as a leader of a team or business has decided to,
okay,
as a leader of a team,
our business has decided to terminate one of my people.
I disagree with their logic,
but I'm not in a position to change the decision.
What should I do to
retain my influence to support the rest of my team yet not compromise my values?
That's a good question.
That's a solid question.
That's a tough question.
It's a little bit tricky without the details of the situation.
But you know,
I,
I wonder what kind of relationship that did the person that asks a question,
I wonder what kind of relationship you have with the senior leadership that
makes those decisions.
Cause you got to remember that our goal is to always have the relationships up
the chain of command so that you can influence those decisions.
And if you have that kind of relationship then you can find out why that
decision got made.
And there might be things that you didn't know about,
some kind of strategic outcome that the decision,
you know,
has had an outback don't an impact on,
right.
So if you didn't know it,
but this guy had some kind of criminal situation going on and you didn't know it
and they can't talk about it cause it's in legal case.
Okay.
If you don't know,
don't speculate,
just go and ask and then you can take whatever those reasons aren't.
You can articulate them,
you know,
down the chain of command.
And again,
you want to,
you want to ask this question in a smart way.
You don't say,
what did bill get fired?
Hey,
why did bill get fired?
No,
you said,
hey,
you know,
from my perspective it seemed like bill was doing a good job.
I want to kind of understand what you were seeing so that I can lead people
better.
If there's anything that I could make up for,
I want to make sure I'm leading.
You know,
like all of those things you want to,
you want to help their ego and make them feel good and make them feel like
you're on board with the program and not make them feel like you're going in
there questioning their call because that's just an attack on their ego.
So this is the,
all these things.
It's a basic things,
right?
The Fun of it.
He called it basic.
These are the fundamental things,
right?
This is the,
this is the way it is standard.
I should just say standard.
That's what I should say.
Standard stuff.
You,
you're trying to build a relationship.
You don't want to go in,
but your head up against their ego.
Then they get more defensive and next to know they're going to fire.
Another one of your guys on your team,
just to prove a point.
You can get yourself,
you can dig yourself that hole,
but if you make your goal,
hey,
I'm going to build the relationship with my boss,
that's what you are trying to do.
Now,
if you find out why,
then you can articulate that to the rest of the team and,
and the way that you maintain your values is by maintaining your values.
Okay.
So just because there's a situation that are decision that gets made that you
don't agree with,
doesn't mean that you compromise your values.
Like your boss can make a decision and that does that,
that you don't agree with.
That doesn't mean that your values are compromised unless it's like an illegal
or it's an immoral or it's an unethical situation,
which by the way,
a firing could be one of those things,
right?
The guy could be firing because he wasn't,
you know what wouldn't hae,
he wouldn't give me the keys to the vehicle for the weekend so I could use it on
my private time and I'm going to fire him now.
Like that's unethical,
right?
There's a problem there.
So now your values definitely if you just remained silently,
you're kind of compromising your values.
So there are times when you may have to stand up,
but bosses make decisions.
That's what they do and we do our best to influence them.
Now if they decide something we don't like,
then yes,
we ask why and if we don't like it,
their explanation,
then we try and explain our case.
We try and explain why we thought bill should have been not been fired.
Now you're not always going to be right.
You're not always going to be right.
And let me tell you something else.
Don't argue about six in one half dozen.
The other bill might've been on the fence and Nate decided,
you know what?
We've had enough trouble with bill.
We're getting rid of them.
And maybe there's valid reasons why bill should have said,
but it's like it could have gone at 60 40 are you going to put your reputation
and your relationship with your boss on the line for over that little thing?
Now again,
I understand firing people is a big deal.
It's not small.
It's not a little thing.
Hmm.
Especially you have a good relationship.
He's on your team.
He's got kids.
You know,
I like all these things are there.
So what are you going to do about it?
Are you going to break down and,
and negatively impact your relationship with your boss over this so that in the
future you have even less influence.
What happens when they go to fire Mike and you haven't and all you did was go,
hey,
why'd you do this?
This was stupid.
Taking a fire Mike and they're not gonna listen to a damn thing.
You said you want to build a relationship with him.
Um,
okay.
You can,
you can explain what your viewpoint is and what you would have done.
Now this is like down,
this is talking to your team.
You can explain what your viewpoint was and what you would have done,
but you also,
you don't want to,
you want to be gentle,
right?
As long as you explain,
if you explain the,
Hey,
I would have done something different.
And you,
you also explained that the boss,
it was a tough decision.
And the boss made the call and that the best thing that we can do as a team is
support the boss so we can garner more influence over these situations in the
future.
That's good.
Okay.
And you know what?
One of the best things you could do here with your team is you can even explain
that it's your fault.
That decision got made,
right?
You say,
look,
I haven't built a good enough relationship with the boss.
That's why he fired bill.
I am working on it.
I'm going to do it better.
We're going to give them the support that he needs so we can stop this thing
from having this type of thing from happening in the future.
So you don't want to throw your boss under the bus.
It's much,
much better to take ownership of it all day,
all day.
If you throw your boss under the bus and you create an antagonistic
relationship,
it's bad for you.
It's bad for your boss and it's bad for your team.
It's bad for your whole organization.
I get it.
And there's a dichotomy here because if your boss totally fired someone with not
good reason and it was a great guy,
and if you just jump on board at the boss,
you're going to look weak.
So do you have to balance that?
Yes.
You have to be honest with your people.
You have to explain what's going on.
That's why I think taking ownership is one of the best things to do.
Your boss does something that's totally out of line.
Hey look,
here's what the boss did.
This is my fault and here's what we do to fix it.
I'm gonna build a better relationship.
I'm going to get more influence.
That's what I need to do.
I obviously let you guys down.
I'm not gonna let it happen again.
Hmm.
That brings your team closer to you rather than saying,
Hey,
the boss was Boston idiot.
He doesn't get it.
You gotta be a,
people don't actually even respect that,
by the way.
They don't actually even respect that.
Yeah.
I'm not saying they say,
hey,
that's a boss's decision and that's,
you know what?
We just support the boss.
I'm not saying that it's a dichotomy.
It's a balance that you have to,
you have to carefully walk,
compromise,
compromise on decisions and directions and plants doesn't hurt.
You know,
he's talking about compromising.
It's like he compromises.
Okay.
That's what it is.
It's compromise.
Okay.
Again,
as long as you're not compromising your personal values,
your ethics,
but compromising about a decision.
That's the way the world works.
Don't let your ego get into it.
Don't let your ego.
So keep building,
keep building relationships,
take ownership in the decisions and support the team.
Keep building relationships,
not just up the chain of command but down so that you can bring it all to
gather.
Next question.
Go question frog man.
Do you think it's always a bad thing to be thought of as slightly unapproachable
as a leader?
Yeah.
So this is another question about the dichotomy of leadership is another
question about balance.
And it's a strangely worded question by the way,
from this,
this a Scotsman who I know it's he cause he uses the question,
he used the word always and usually always is always a never.
Right.
When you use those,
they usually don't hold up as a,
it always a bad thing,
but then he kind of,
he kind of softens the always by by saying slightly on a project also.
So we give him a,
a fairly low grade on his question.
Uh,
but luckily that the concept of the question,
we give him a high grade,
which is,
is it,
should you be unapproachable,
slightly unapproachable?
Should you be,
that's the real question.
Should you be slightly unapproachable as a leader?
Well,
there's,
this is,
this is a question about dichotomy.
The question is about balance.
Do you want to have people approach you about every little problem or issue as a
boss?
Do you want to have that happen?
No.
You don't know,
right?
Do you want to be the easy button where you have to answer every single question
and make every decision?
If you're too approachable,
that's where you're going to find yourself.
Now,
at the same time,
at the other end of the spectrum,
do you want your team to never approach you ever because you're on approachable?
Yeah.
No,
you don't want that.
Do you want them to,
to be scared or intimidated from giving you good,
honest feedback or good suggestions about the way you're doing things?
Do you,
do you not want that to happen because you're too unapproachable?
Of course not.
So those are the dichotomies.
You can be too,
too approachable and be the easy button.
Or you can be too aloof and too distant and too unapproachable that you don't
even know what's happening on the front lines and you don't get any input from
them.
The extremes are bad.
So what you want to do is you want to bounce those two dichotomies,
be in the middle,
be approachable,
but not overly approachable and you'll be good.
Pretty straight forward.
I think we got time for one more.
Sure.
Jocko,
what do you do when you're broken?
What do I do when I'm broken?
I'm broken.
I relish it.
That's what I'm gonna do.
I'm going to use it
because
if I'm broken,
then I just found my limitations.
And until I know what my limitations are,
how can I push me?
How can I get better?
But once,
once I see it,
once I feel it,
once I see where I was broken,
then I can attack that weakness.
I can fill in that gap.
I can reinforce that breach.
If you break,
it means it's time to fortify your wheel to make it stronger.
They look,
there's,
there's all kinds of different ways to break.
You can break physically,
you can break mentally,
you can break your heart,
you can break your spirit and none of those are fun and all of those are going
to leave a mark.
But the mark that they leave can be the mark of victory.
Or it can be the mark of defeat
because every time you break in,
in every way that you break,
while it's a chance,
it's definitely a chance for you to give up and for you to just to fall apart.
But there's also opportunity,
there's opportunity to get stronger and get smarter and get faster and get
tougher and get more stable and get more resilient and get
okay
better.
When you break,
you have the opportunity to show the world the whole world what you are really
made off.
So,
so if you break,
if you break,
the fight isn't over.
In fact,
if you break,
the fight is just beginning
and as you are all up and out of that dismal and wretched place covered and
you're covered in blood and sweat and dirt and filth as you rise above what you
were
and as you take the form of of who you are supposed to be,
you will see that in the very act of standing up in the very act of fighting on
you will become a and you will remain
unbroken.
And I think that's all I've got for tonight.
So
Echo Charles,
speaking of getting stronger and faster and tougher and better.
Sure.
Better.
Maybe you got some ways we could support ourselves with those goals.
Facilitate getting better and stronger.
I like it.
Pushed the breaking point.
I'll tell you that.
That'll push a breaking point.
Especially the,
the joint warfare part,
the whole thing coming,
right?
They're coming in hot.
No,
that's okay.
So we'll start with the origin,
right?
Origin American made.
Yeah,
we're,
we're at the origin immersion camp right now.
We're sorry that you're not here.
Actually we're up here in Maine or we're happy that you are here or yeah,
if you're here,
we're happy you're here.
Yeah,
definitely.
There's a lot of people in the game.
A lot of people heard us say on the podcast,
come to the origin camp and they're here and guess what?
In the forums it.
Yep.
Yeah.
And for us it's awesome.
Every level.
How many black belts are here?
Dang,
I don't know.
A lot.
Yeah.
And how many white belts are here?
A lot.
Yeah.
How many people have never trained you to a lot?
A decent number to put into context.
This is the,
I think we had to do this right or,
or we just nonetheless,
this is what we did.
We're breaking up.
Yeah.
So we're,
everyone convenes in the morning right before on the big mats and they're like,
hey,
who hasn't had any experience at all?
Or you know,
under a however a month or a month or something like that.
Go with Jocko guys over here to this other Matt.
The other Matt was full.
It was full.
So
the point is,
it's not just like people who want to just,
you know,
get after their Jujitsu game and they'd been in it for,
years and years and they want to camp out and do Jujitsu.
It's not that.
Yeah.
And it's cool.
There's a lot of different instruments.
Like,
yes.
Like yesterday the deco and I taught the top the new Jujitsu people.
Yeah.
Today.
I think it was the deco and Hoffa and I stayed down with the,
the,
the colored belts.
Right.
I think there's,
I think there's probably the same number of black belts here as people that
their first day ever on the mats was here.
Yeah.
I think it's about the same number.
What,
like 2020 of each,
20 people that have never trained you just to move forward and 20 people to have
their black belts in Jiu Jitsu.
There's like those two.
And then there's everyone in between this guy.
Um,
I was talking to this guy,
he's like,
he goes,
yeah,
today's my second day.
I was like,
Oh yeah.
Right on.
Where were,
you know,
when was your first day where it was?
He goes,
Oh yeah,
here.
Yesterday.
I was like,
Oh yeah,
I forgot.
I came one day after.
He is sweet.
Crazy.
But that's where we are right now.
Or if everyone did the factory.
Yeah.
The orange factory in Farmington,
Maine saw where everything is made.
Yeah.
Big Time.
So what do we have?
GIES rash guard.
There's a new,
you guys were extra fired up about extra,
extra fired.
Oh,
was that,
is that a deal thing?
It's,
well,
we can't show anybody,
but we do have a,
a new g coming.
Yeah.
And we'll say it's,
it's very awesome.
Legit.
Yeah.
Nonetheless.
Have origin.
The best gs.
The best geese.
Hands down.
Everyone knows already.
It's like,
what do you call it is common knowledge anyway.
Made in America.
100% made in America.
Also rash guards,
all kinds of stuff.
Those shorts,
those new shorts,
they came out with approved big time.
Yeah.
But yeah,
they got some,
some sweat suits to joggers,
shirts and whatnot.
Oh,
good stuff.
Supplements.
Yeah.
You know,
uh,
the supplements,
these are supplements that,
well,
how do I pick what supplements I'm going to make?
It's supplements that I've taken and dial them in the protein,
the milk tastes good is good.
No sugar.
What's it got one carb to carbs,
something like that.
Yeah,
I think just a little tasty dessert.
What is really where you were talking about joint warfare.
[inaudible] drone warfare.
We got Krill oil.
All good.
We got discipline.
You're pre,
I saw a lot of people drinking discipline,
like heading to the maps.
A lot of people that day as I plan.
Yeah man,
someone said it was in that big cooler.
I didn't go over there and check.
That would make sense.
Yeah,
it's,
so as we get that,
that's origin main.
What'd you mean?
Dot Com.
You get all that.
That's our company.
We're making all this stuff and we're gonna keep making stuff until,
until we make everything that we use.
That's the goal.
Yeah.
And these are especially the joint stuff man,
that the joint stuff,
one is the one that it's like an everyday go to in my case it that's monk to
where I every day and pounding Moca on the mulching.
And and you,
you surprised me earlier cause I asked you because you always say you're on the
milk train fully,
fully or you say you're fully on the milk train usually.
Yeah.
Usually you say you're on the milk train fully
and I asked you could someone be partially on the milk train and you said that
that was in fact possible.
I don't know how that's possible but well you know how many milk,
how many moke a de certifies you as being on the milk train?
At least one a day.
Okay.
That's pretty,
that's doable model.
That's not crazy.
But if you're pounding the milk every day,
that's the monk train regardless when you're mostly on the mall.
Okay.
That's a Mocha is fully on the mock trip.
That's like two,
sometimes three.
Imagine.
So basically with every meal,
two scoops not to hit two situations.
To me,
two scoops is minerals.
That's one drink middle school.
See that's the thing is I've got this new thing where I do these little hitters
situation.
Theo von,
we're hanging out.
We were talking about to hit us but he doesn't even know about more.
I got to send him some milk so we can have a hit her.
I hit her is one scoop,
one scoop.
It doesn't,
that's a thing is it doesn't make,
cause when I have a double shot of milk,
I'm full bright.
There's no,
there's no room.
I,
you know,
I'm not an animal.
Take some time to digest.
Right.
If that's a meal,
basically you just day to stake a big one.
That's how I feel.
Well now if I have a one scoop hitter just to get one of those hit us,
they hit her then then you can go.
Yeah,
you can keep moving.
You can work out like 45 minutes later you can be in the gym.
Could be on the map.
That makes sense.
Actually.
Now that I'm thinking about it,
I don't take it like I'll do it for every time.
Like if I work out,
that's all eat after.
I work out well most of the time,
but okay.
So here's the situation.
Got Home the other day,
woke up at old crappy hotel somewhere early in the morning,
early morning flight.
Woke up,
didn't work out at the hotel early morning cause I knew I was heading back to my
house where I could be in my home gym.
So wait,
it got homeless hungry.
Did a hitter did it.
Okay.
Yeah cause I was hung cause the neck the night before,
guess what didn't eat,
why didn't it was working,
so got home,
it was,
I don't know,
it was like Tan got home,
wanted to wanting to eat something but still wanted to work out before lunch
hitter.
Okay,
makes sense.
Yeah.
And then boom,
still got work to do.
I think that's why I come on time payment wasn't that hungry?
Yeah.
The header.
So you just sort of fit it in your whole thing but yeah.
And then consider the joint warfare and the Krill oil boom every day.
Joint squared away.
Yeah.
I didn't mean for that to rhyme,
but it does.
So all good skills.
Also good way to support.
We have a store.
Technically Jocko has a store.
I helped make it so we have a store affirmative.
Either way.
It's called chocolate store rash guards are available.
Rash guards under Aggie?
Yes or no?
What's your opinion?
Well yeah,
whatever you like.
First of all.
Some people mandate it.
Oh,
there's some schools that it is mandatory.
You will wear a rash guard under your gay.
Okay.
There are some schools where you're not allowed to are you lot can you where I'm
an attorney at some tournaments you're allowed to,
some tournaments are not allowed to.
There's some rules out there.
So find that out and then you can get one of these rash guards that say
something on,
I'm like God after it or something like that.
Yup.
And Yeah,
rash guards,
tee shirts.
You can get hats.
Yeah,
I'm good to have on their flex fit if you're into it.
Okay.
Jackals not into flex fit.
I Degas did it.
We figured out the numbers yet to figure out what's more popular.
No.
Which one?
Which one do people like more?
We don't know yet.
I don't know.
I remember the family member,
the flex fit phase,
but I think we're out of it,
man.
I think we're back to,
I think everyone in Americans back to truckers.
That's kind of what we're doing now.
I think that's what America,
I think America is on board with trucker hats.
I could be wrong though.
Cause we know my fashion sense is completely in the doughnut.
Yeah,
you're right.
You said about that.
So yeah,
I dunno.
I'll find out and report back.
But if you want a shirt,
you know these shirts then the ones that say discipline equals freedom.
Boom.
That's where you can get them chocolate store.
Also the one with jock head on it.
This is good.
More than a few people have said,
hey man,
I really like you know your stuff,
but I'm not wearing to share with your giant head on it and I'm not.
It's not for everybody,
for everyone,
not for everybody.
Somebody said,
hey,
is there a shirt with your head on it?
To me?
Oh and it reminded me a while.
Yes it is.
John designed the Dang.
Sure.
Yeah.
So that's one little factoid.
What's a factoid?
Small fast,
small factor that many people don't know.
A lot of the designs that we're part of like,
you know,
echelon front and you know some of these designs,
jock,
you made the designs.
You didn't make the official one,
but you with your left hand or whatever.
Drew the design concept is mine.
Yeah.
Your concept is mine.
But you physically drew it though.
That's the thing.
Like you said,
hey,
I want it to do this and no,
you know,
you like drew it out.
A picture's worth a thousand words.
I'm not writing you a thousand word paragraph.
And what that echelon front segment,
what's the Jocko podcast thing is going to look like or what the Jocko white
tea,
whatever.
Couldn't draw it.
There it is.
Do it.
Yeah.
So you're technically a designer.
You're the idea guy,
eh?
Yeah.
People don't know that.
Now they do.
And then the last is called Jocko store.com.
Yeah.
Men Get something represent big time.
Big Time.
Also subscribe to the podcast if you haven't already on iTunes and stitcher.
If you have android,
that's the big one for android.
Okay.
Yes,
I think the iTunes or for Android,
I dunno,
either way,
whatever you use to stream podcasts,
subscribe if you haven't already.
Don't forget about the warrior kid podcast working on,
we've got 16 out right now,
I think maybe 17 out right now.
But anyways,
more common on that and a lot of the good feedback I'm getting is that the kids
want to listen to them over and over and over again,
which is Kinda cool.
So I'll make more so kids can listen to more of them.
And there's stuff in there.
It's uncle Jake answering questions.
You might think it's like questions up for a little tiny kids that you don't get
anything out of.
I think was just talking to some people at Camp,
the shocking this one,
one girl and she was saying,
yeah,
she's like,
I'm totally into the warrior kid podcasts.
Yeah,
a,
come on.
Amen.
Number 10 right now it's really good.
So those questions are for everybody.
I'm like,
Hey,
right on it.
So yeah,
Uncle Jake has a little something to teach everybody,
you know.
And that's the way it is.
Also Youtube.
We've got youtube,
youtube channel.
If you want to see echoes,
legit videos.
We also,
oh,
the videos we spoke of so we'll get,
we need to get those done.
Maybe when we get back to San Diego.
Yeah,
the two um,
life chance column.
Yeah.
I want to say life changing but they two instructional life videos.
About tips.
Yeah.
That's what it is.
Yeah,
that's,
that's much more appropriate.
That's good.
So you can also see echoes,
legit videos,
enhanced enhanced videos too.
Yeah,
youtube is good.
A good way to support also on it on [inaudible] dot com slash Jocko by the way,
that's where you can get good workout gear.
Legit work up here when a very up your workout.
Also they have a lot of cool other stuff.
There's this tribe blend peanut butter,
not peanut butter.
It's peanut butter,
almond butter and I think cashew.
So it's like an enhanced peanut butter scenario.
That's what you use it for.
It's good.
Anyway,
they got a lot of cool stuff on there like that,
like warrior bars and whatnot.
Where at bars can be.
It's like a
beef jerky but not jerky.
It's like a look at it.
It's good.
Super um,
dance in like protein and nutrient scenario anyway on it.com/joe.
Good spot.
Don't forget we've got the psychological psychological warfare album that you
can get that has discussions,
tracks if you will about how to overcome some moments of weakness that you might
hit.
And we are working on the next one.
We're not quite there yet so we're working on it.
But yeah,
psychological warfare,
it's,
you can get that anywhere.
Itunes,
Google,
whatever MP3 platforms are out there.
Yeah,
to get them all.
So Jocko white tea.
Yes,
they'll phenomenon.
It's funny like I know and people know Randy.
I know it never really was into tea actually.
Even when the,
the,
what do you call it,
the dry to dry him.
I was like cool.
Cause I was,
you know,
I'm on the bus.
You were just,
you were just playing,
you're just going along with it,
which it to away game.
They,
here's the thing though,
I was going along with it.
I was giving,
I was like,
what do you call him to come back and listen to those podcasts and see if you
are trying to act like you in the game.
Even though that we now know you weren't going to make you whole your whole
deal.
Suspect foot put it this way.
I was in the game,
but it was like,
because I was like on the hype train.
You know how you know how like when I was like,
hey man,
everybody,
hey,
everyone's doing this new thing and you're like,
oh you,
I'm down there.
That just made you sound worse.
Well,
hey man,
that's the truth and everyone's going to be higher.
We even know what you're saying right now.
It's true about it.
Well maybe it's all hype.
Maybe,
maybe not.
You've got to find out for yourself.
That's the thing.
That's the question.
So I take it,
I'm like,
hey,
cool,
cool.
But it kind of,
you know,
kind of wore off.
I don't drink tea that much,
but they cans came out and then what am I doing?
Pounding,
tricking tea all day.
Is that height?
No,
because I wouldn't be pounding it in every day.
See what I'm saying?
You wouldn't be texting me for more boxes to be delivered to your home if you
weren't in the actual teacher in.
Yeah,
we wouldn't be running out.
I'll tell you that.
That wouldn't be the case.
Jp.
Jp sends me pictures of just Jocko white tea.
He asked me to do today.
How much,
how much is there any amount of Jocko white tea that's not,
he got to see her.
You got to find is like fully on the train and he might be one level over the
train and into like the zone of whatever addiction.
Uh,
yeah.
So Jocko books got some out there way.
The Warrior kid marks mission.
Those two books,
man.
That's one thing being up here.
How many,
how many people have come up to me and said,
my kid's doing Jujitsu.
My kids do an awesome school.
My kids doing pull ups.
Good.
Thank you so much for writing.
The warrior could books.
So if you want your kid to work out to train hard to eat,
right,
to study,
to do good in school.
Hey,
those sound like they might be good things.
Yes.
Get your book,
get the way of the warrior kit.
You kid is not going to listen to you as much as they're going to listen to an
outside source.
Make the outside source something that you agree with something that's telling
them to work hard.
Study hard,
train hard
way.
The warrior kid in Mark's mission also got the discipline equals freedom field
manual.
I like seeing how many people give this as a gift to people you know.
Just got this as a gift.
I see that on social media and then they get off stoked on it,
so that's a little instruction manual on how to get after it,
period.
If you want the audio version,
it is not on audible.
It is on iTunes,
Amazon music,
Google play as an album.
Extreme ownership.
That's
the book of life and I wrote combat leadership lessons that you can apply to
your business,
to your life dichotomy of leadership.
Listen to podcast one 38 we read a couple excerpts from it that's coming out
September 25th if you want to get a copy of first a dish,
order it now.
If you want third a dish,
fourth,
a dish.
If you want to be walking around with a big flag that says,
Hey,
I procrastinated,
I'm a procrastinator.
I waited,
I didn't execute,
I didn't prioritize and execute.
I didn't keep things simple.
If you want to have that flag,
you want to support that flag,
hold off,
don't order it.
Get the fourth of dish visit dishes are going to go out quick because here's the
deal.
The the publishers that are conservative,
younger.
Yeah,
I know your first books,
your first few books have sold well,
but you know,
that's no guarantee for the next one.
We might just mean know we probably should only run this many and we don't know.
You know,
just to see anyone and we can run more tape.
Take it takes in a little bit more time for people to get them.
It's okay and they'll live like,
no,
actually they won't.
They'll actually die.
We'll get it in time.
So,
uh,
get that first a dish going make now this is cool if we as a group order enough
now the everyone in that first group we'll get first to dish cause they'll print
it more first additions,
which is the goal that way more people don't have to bear the shame.
And,
and some people say,
Oh I,
you know,
I'm,
I had first the dish but I gave it away and now I have a new one.
Don't do that.
Keep the first a dish that's of like when you,
somebody sent me the British,
a dish of about face first.
Ocdish British or dish is different cover of about face.
So somebody sent me from England,
uh,
about face the book England copy British one.
So I got that in my bookshelf.
That's different.
Then one day I want to,
I want to take pictures.
So I like have things that are the same.
Like when I like I have flip flops,
I wear flip flops around.
Sure.
I have nine pairs.
All the same I have about face.
I got 10,
12 copies of it just racked up.
Cool.
I got my same watch.
You want me to these watches I got,
I think I got six.
One of them might be broken.
No,
a couple of them are broken,
but I keep them for spare parts.
[inaudible]
what kind of running shoes do I have with all the same workout shoes there?
My workout shoes,
my running shoes,
all the same.
Boom.
The what about my workout clothing?
We're all the same.
Never think about it.
What about that?
Sure.
That victory should shares the same thing.
How many of these I've got?
I got a lot of them.
We could go in my house and just like take a picture of watches,
flip flops,
sneakers,
uh,
shorts.
You my shorts.
I wear the same damn shorts all the time.
So where does,
where does doing it?
But uh,
for sending me and I'm going to send the person that sent me the British a dish.
I'm gonna send him some signed copies of
some books of mine.
Um,
a on top of that,
we've got a leadership consulting company.
Me,
Leif,
Babin,
JP Denelle,
Dave Burke,
Flynn Cochran,
Mike Cirelli.
We solve problems through leadership.
That's what we do now.
If you want us to come in as consultants and look at what your situation is and
help you align your leadership,
go to Asheville on front.com if you want one of us to come and speak to your
company,
go to Asheville on front.com that's where you don't call a speaking agency.
Just go to Asheville on front.com we have the muster real close to sold out.
I'm not sure if it's sold out yet,
but monster zero zero six San Francisco,
October 17th and 18th registered extreme ownership.com that's the premier
leadership conference in the world.
I think actually knowing the universe.
Sure.
Because I don't think they have any good leadership conferences on Mars.
I think ours is better if they do have one.
It's probably all hot
cold,
so yeah.
Monster occasionally still get questions like,
Hey,
I'm 58 years old and I have a bad knee.
Would I be able to do the monster of the answer is yes.
The muster is anyone can do the physical demands at the muster are very,
very little,
if any.
If you don't,
you don't have to come and do the morning pts,
the morning physical training.
You can completely not come to that.
You can,
you're more than welcome to come and if you come you can just watch or you could
come or you could do the minimum that you can do and that's fine.
So there's no minimum physical standards for participation at the muster if you
feel like you need to Com com and also on top of the muster we have another
event that we're doing for the uniform personnel.
So military law enforcement,
border patrol,
firefighters,
corrections officers.
I've been adding that one in paramedics,
other first responders roll call zero zero one September 21st in Dallas,
Texas.
It's a one day leadership seminar for those folks in those dynamic leadership
environments.
Registration is gonna close,
so register.
You can also register for that and the muster@extremeownership.com and of course
we also now have EFO Overwatch.
We are connecting SPEC ops veterans and the companies that want to hire spec
ops,
veterans and Combat Aviation,
combat aviation and SPEC ops companies need leaders out there and we are,
we have leaders that were connected with,
so we're trying to place them,
uh,
that's Efo,
overwatch.com and right now we've got an awesome response from all of our other
brothers and sisters in the military.
So we're working on something right now to open up this everyone
and until we see you at the monster or at the roll call or maybe we won't even
see you until another year from now at the immersion camp next time in Maine.
But until then,
if you want to continue hanging out with us virtually,
we are all up on the interwebs,
on Instagram,
Twitter and on daisy.
Oh I
echo is add echo Charles and I am at Jocko Willink.
And finally thanks to the military people around the world holding the line
world wide a thank you for your service and in America,
police,
law enforcement,
correctional officers,
firefighters,
border patrol paramedics are the first responders.
Thank you for holding the line here at home
and to everyone else.
Remember
that life is not easy,
but it's not supposed to be easy.
Life is a test and it's a hard test.
And sometimes you might do great on that test
and that's super,
but sometimes that test doesn't go so well
that sometimes you might falter and sometimes you might fail and sometimes you
might even break in.
When that happens,
use it.
Use it to make yourself faster and stronger and smarter and better.
And take a look at how and why you broke a so edit does not happen again.
Identify your weaknesses.
Come up with a plan of attack and get after it.
And until next time,
this is echo and Jocko out.